[Music]
so
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
it's the mother of all talk shows all
right it's the open university of the
airwaves
there are no tuition fees and you are
positively encouraged
to talk back to the undereducated
teacher
that will be me it is the college of
knowledge
and we'll be branching out this evening
into some fields of study
we haven't visited for quite some time
including the royal family as
a brouhaha and opera
begins to brew over in the united states
between harry and megan another american
wife
tears apart the british royal family at
least that's the narrative
according to some you can have your say
on our poll and we'll of course be
looking
at the british and american political
scenes
particularly the british one where
cirque
starmer the labor leader having promised
to be
20 points ahead of boris johnson
now finds himself 13 points behind
and independence which was riding high
on its horse when i arrived back in
scotland has now been knocked off in the
lists
my jousting is working the snp have gone
into reverse
and those who support the maintenance of
the union
of great britain are now back in charge
of course there's time things can change
manchester united just beat manchester
city two nil
some fools say there's no god i'll be
here for the next three hours
it's the mother of all talk shows so
fasten your
seat belts it's rock and roll radio with
pictures
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
now i am not of course a royalist and
you wouldn't normally find me giving
over some precious broadcast time
for a royal story but this one simply
cannot be ignored here we have a
situation where
the duke of edinburgh the grandfather
aged 100 is lying in a hospital bed
having just had an operation at the age
of 100
and his grandson and his fancy wife from
the united states
hollywood second or third division
are slandering the mother of
the family the queen herself
it seems extraordinary crass
timing to be attacking the royal family
in britain for money because make no
mistake about it that's what it is it
isn't
out of a burning determination to get
something off their chest harry and
megan are doing this
for the money and my goodness it's big
money
a 100 million dollar
deal with netflix a 10
million dollar deal with opera winfrey
and presumably the book sales and other
spin-offs to go with it there is no
justification for a young man who
lived a life of spectacular privilege
paid for by the taxpayer including their
fancy
royal wedding to turn on the rest of
their family
in this degrading and spectacular way
and of course it has got the popular
press and not just
the popular press in a frenzy
here in britain and it brings
forth the old saw that happened
before i was born but i grew up hearing
about how an american woman mrs wallace
simpson
had devastated the british royal family
despite being
twice divorced and multiply
compromised at least in several divorce
cases
as correspondent mrs wallace simpson and
american
third division society debutant
well perhaps that's not the one for
managed to
win the heart of the very
short serving king of england who then
was forced to abdicate from the throne
in order to marry her to be fair they
stayed together then for the rest of
their
lives but it prejudiced a lot of people
against second third division society
women from the united states marrying
into the royal family
and yet when this star
shall i put it that way of a second or
third ray american soap opera called
suits
married into the royal family there was
a very great deal
of goodwill i even watched that royal
wedding
myself didn't you but it very quickly
turned sour and we'll be investigating
this evening
whether or not the fact that meghan
markle is mixed race had anything at all
to do with it where the royals
called and unwelcoming to her because of
her
color now if you ask the late princess
diana who was
as white as could be and got a pretty
cold and
unwelcome uh entry into the
royal family firm themselves well
we'll be talking about that in fact
we've got a poll
running on it let me give it to you now
do you believe megan and harry
have been victimized by the queen a
yes b no c
the publicity hounds you can vote now
on my twitter feed we'll be talking to
caleb mopan
about the current political situation in
the united states
where joe biden though he doesn't now
know it
is getting into his stride as the
president
of the united states he's even launching
bombing raids
on syria meet the new boss he's just
like the old boss and
he's threatening all kinds of
horrors down the road for russia
and china and all the fancy promises
about rejoining the iran nuclear deal
have all turned to ash in his mouth
there now will be no american rejoining
the nuclear deal not least because
joe just killed 22
iranians in syria
in retaliation he said for pro-iranian
iraqi militias continuing to fire
mainly harmless rockets are american
military installations in a country they
have been
asked to leave by the sovereign
parliament
of iraq and by the overwhelming majority
of iraqi people hats off to his holiness
the pope by the way pope francis has
just toured iraq in what undoubtedly was
the most
dangerous expedition of his papacy
and he did it to try and bring about
reconciliation
and stability in iraq unfortunately the
united states administration headed by
one of the pope's
followers is not actually taking a leaf
out of his book but then tony blair
proved
that you can be a catholic and defy the
pope
it's easy if there's blood on your hands
and joe biden now has blood on his hands
just a couple of months after taking
office we'll be talking to caleb mopa
the sharpest of american political
commentators
about that and i'll be talking to you
about the british political
scene now when jeremy corbyn was the
leader of the labour party he wasn't
terribly successful
in the end though he came very close to
becoming the prime minister
of britain in 2017
but by 2019 the brexit issue and others
had brought him to his knees and he was
very convincingly defeated by boris
johnson
and those that were trying to overthrow
jeremy corbyn and that was rather a lot
of
labor members of parliament and for
rather a long time in fact
from the first day that he took office
always argued that
anybody else but jeremy corbyn
would be 20 points ahead
of boris johnson well
there is a poll this week a very big one
a very comprehensive one with lots of
subsets
but the big headline is that sir keith
starmer the
leader of the labour party is not 20
points ahead of
boris johnson in fact he's 13
points behind boris johnson
a feat almost unimaginable
given that the british economy is in
free fall
and there's a 135 000
dead people from the catastrophic
lack of preparation and good order
in the british response to that
coronavirus
any leader let me paraphrase the
playwrights
any leader would be 20 points ahead
of boris johnson in those circumstances
any leader apart from the one that they
have got
sir keith starmer it must be
dawning on two separate parts of
the labour party let me deal with the
biggest part
first it must be dawning on those who
remain
loyal to the tony blair
gospel that keith
starmer is a block of wood
with a wig of rather fine hair
so wooden that the birds are nesting in
him
so clunky
that he cannot even take the knee
without looking ridiculous i just can't
wait for his
attempt to lay a wreath at the senator
he'll approach the senator
like the tin man in the wizard of oz
this man is a disaster and the blairites
must now see it i believe they do see it
in fact i know that they do see it
so watch out sir keith those that
got rid of corbin and put you there are
going to
hoist you on your own art
and they're going to replace you with an
even truer keeper of the true blair
faith
and the other section of the labour
party
those that remain loyal to the program
at least
of jeremy corbyn are going to have to
face
a brutal fact that if you
thought keith starmer was bad what is
coming down the pipe
is far far worse it'll be david
miliband who'll come back and will
contest a by-election
in the hope that he can get into
parliament and before you could say
jack robinson sir keith will be gone
and david miliband will be crowned as
the prince
over the water are you still going to
stay
in the labour party in those
circumstances
what's wrong with you those of you who
parrot this cry don't hear it quite so
much now
the parrot the cry of staying and
fighting
staying and first of all what's the
point of being in a political party
when you've got to spend all your time
and energy fighting
other people in your own party
that sounds like a recipe for
wasting your political life to me
but when you're doing it knowing that
you haven't
the slightest the remotest possibility
of ever winning that fight then you are
fooling yourself if you think you
are standing up for the working class
one of the subsets of this latest poll
is that amongst working class people
the conservatives are precisely
twice as popular as labour
amongst the working class just think
about that
for a moment in scotland there have been
another set
of opinion polls when i
arrived back in scotland everyone said
separatism was inevitable the union was
dead dissolved the union
was everywhere the snp were on track
to an overall majority
in the scottish parliament something
that
by design was meant to be impossible
the snp were winning out of the park
until i re-entered the country and
re-entered politics in scotland
i'm very happy to tell you that this day
the polls show that the snp will have no
majority
at all and the majority of people in two
separate polls today
want britain to remain uh want britain
to remain
united they want scotland to remain
within the united kingdom
55 to 45 we won the once in a lifetime
generation
in 2014. if you uh include the don't
knows
uh which broke nine to one
for remaining in the united kingdom last
time in 2014
we're back almost exactly at 55
to 45 in fact we're at 56
to 44. so i'm a happy man
not just because manchester united beat
the league leaders
manchester city i'm happy because the
tide
has turned in scotland and i've had
a little bit to do with that
i'm very proud to say so we're taking
calls on
all of these matters in the course of
the next
two hours and 40 minutes here's my
trusty young assistant colleague
young james is it all uh
pouring in my goodness it's all royal do
you believe that megan and harry
have been victimized by the queen 1538
of you have voted
and i haven't even finished speaking yet
a yes 14 of you
believe that megan and harry have been
victimized by the queen
no say 58 percent of you and another
28 of you denounced the pair
as publicity hounds 1538 people
have voted you can vote now and for the
next
well just a little less than two hours
on my twitter feed let me give you some
of the
social media response which is uh coming
in thick and fast
john says quite frankly i think the
behavior
of harry and megan throughout has been
deplorable
she like a previous american divorcee
thought she could marry into the royal
family and change things to her liking
and then started spitting bile and spite
when she couldn't
then the dash for cash harsh
but probably true john gary says i'm
just hoping
whatever is said we can put them out of
our media on a daily basis but i doubt
it
frankly the pair bore to the bone
and john says give me a break the only
time i ever heard of them getting a hard
time
was when they were in the papers
complaining about getting a hard time
and paul says they have not been
victimized by the queen
the queen understands that to be a
working royal
you must be apolitical megan wanted to
be royal
and a political activist you cannot be
both
and nadia says i don't think they have
been victimized by the queen
herself i feel like it's an outdated
system
that megan found strange and that never
set well with harry she must have
studied it though before marrying into
it
crystal says they just want to do
anything to stay
relevant and in the press she knew what
she was marrying into
they wanted to walk away they are most
certainly
not victims and tim says they have
created
victim personas as their unique selling
point
it's a bit pathetic really and alan says
for a couple that wanted privacy they
are certainly courting
lots of media attention in the united
states
they had the chance for a quieter royal
life by living in canada
remaining within the commonwealth could
have been the workable compromise
for both sides it's all about
them and james says look harry
isn't even a royal he's just oh no i
can't say that james
that would be unkind amelia says a pair
of spoiled
two-bit nothings who didn't get what
they wanted
she's acting at taking on the diana roll
and dan says never heard of her before
he got involved with her
she's not important interesting or
relevant jonathan says
of course they have been victimized they
are getting a press kicking
and megan is being investigated whilst
racism
pedophilia and abusive relationships in
the royal family
are tolerated and enabled now jonathan's
got a point there
why is there not more discussion about
prince andrew
and his failure to cooperate with the
fbi
not rather a more important
alleged offense and steve says
strange how megan sues a paper to
protect the privacy of her own family
and yet harry is quite happy for her to
wash the dirty laundry of his own
in this interview his grandfather is 99
his grandmother 94. the man's a disgrace
and sam says harry and megan are a waste
of space
they are being disrespectful to the
queen especially as prince philip
is currently in hospital it's all me me
me with them lately
i could go on and on and on because
i'm told that our printer has just
broken
under the pressure of the social media
that's coming in
let me take a 60 second break and then
it's the great caleb mopan radio
sputnik
our world is full of
mysteries the lost
city of atlantis
[Music]
area 51
who killed jfk
the clock on dr angie brass
wall it's a conspiracy man
we have a right to know shut
it you nutter
the senseless made sensible
only on the mother of all talk shows
sputnik has been launched to give you a
closer look at everything happening in
the world
radio sputnik telling the untold
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
now if you are watching as well as
listening the show as
last week 490 000
of you did that's quite a big audience
isn't it
just viewers 490 000
last week that's despite the efforts of
mr algorithm
who's ever active then please if you're
watching
on facebook share now with all of your
contacts all of your friends
you can watch on my facebook uh you can
watch on rt's multiple facebook
pages you can watch on my youtube on
rt's multiple youtube pages or
on twitter where yet again for the fifth
week in a row um a record number
of people watched on their telephone i
say that as the man who never thought
that 5g
would catch on who's gonna watch tv on
their telephone
i distinctly remember saying but for
five weeks in a row
uh new records are being broken you can
also
watch on my telegram channel and one day
i'll remember the
address of that you can also watch of
course on twitch
as i now know to my cost a significant
number of you
are here's my telegram channel t dot me
forward slash george galloway t dot me
forward slash george galloway do follow
me
on telegram do get onto telegram
because if algorithm continues at the
rate
he's going that might be our last
redoubt
that might be our stalingrad
now caleb mopan is my
rt america i work there monday to friday
every evening 7 pm london time
and i often catch his reports
which are stupendously well devised
and delivered i consider him the
smartest
of our american correspondents and he
joins me now with much to say
on what exactly is going on in the u.s
caleb thanks for joining
us i know neither of us would normally
care
to talk about these matters but
the big transatlantic story this evening
is oprah winfrey about to broadcast
uh a story involving prince harry
and princess megan dishing the dirt
on the british royal family is anyone in
the united states
interested in that well there certainly
is an upsurge of interest across
social media uh i think our leaders in
the united states are pretty good at
distracting us
and the celebrity culture is a great way
to take our minds off of the crisis here
in the united states
a pandemic mass unemployment
infrastructure
failing cultural polarization but
nothing like some good old celebrity
gossip something that oprah winfrey has
been
crafting and perfecting the art of for
decades i think people are very excited
to see what will be said
what a great pity let's focus back then
on what you rightly say is far more
important one might have expected
that the democrats would hit the ground
running
that the shape of a democratic party-led
united states would already be hoving
into view
they control both houses of the
uh the congress and they hold the white
house
they have untrammeled power how they're
doing with it
they're doing absolutely nothing um it
is kind of amazing when obama came into
office he came in
swinging ready to do a lot of things
when trump came into office he came in
swinging
ready to do a lot of things but the
biden administration has been
pretty silent pretty quiet and pretty
undramatic uh not many dramatic actions
not many swift moves
uh it seems like they're almost waiting
to see
what is going to happen and what they
might do there i there many suspect
there are some kind of backroom
negotiations
taking place because you'll remember it
was a very broad coalition
that biden set up in order to defeat
donald trump in addition to the
usual liberal folks that are aligned
with the democratic party you had a
whole section of the neo-conservatives
rallying around
john bolton who backed joe biden now you
have
different factions uh and different
alliances that have been made
and it's not exactly clear what
direction the biden administration will
take they took office on a platform of
were not trump and other than that what
exactly is holding the coalition
together
when it comes to international
situations there's not a clear
agreement within the biden camp when it
comes to domestic policy there's very
clear
disagreement and we saw you know bernie
sanders just get shot down
by the democratic party leadership when
he pushed to raise the minimum wage
and uh it's not clear what the biden
administration is going to do all the
statements that we hear
from from biden himself from vice
president kamala harris from the new
secretary of state anthony blanken are
all very very bland
very very mild very very quiet um it's
not clear what they're going to do
many suspect though when some kind of uh
some kind of agreement is reached
behind the scenes we may see some very
very dramatic moves but right now the
administration is looking rather meek
let's come back to the domestic and
stick
to the international for a moment one of
the very few
pre-election promises made by joe biden
was that he would take america back
into the iran nuclear deal last week
he killed in cold blood 22 iranians
in an act of collective punishment a
weird kind of
collective punishment he killed 22
people iranians who were in syria
for a crime he says was committed
by iraqis supported by iran
in iraq so what he did was
illegal but just as important
as being illegal it was absolutely
stupid wasn't it because it represented
at the end of any hopes of rapprochement
with iran
indeed i mean look the iranians made
huge concessions at the negotiating
table
to enact the jcpoa i mean at the
negotiating table they gave up their
peaceful nuclear energy program
almost entirely uh they made other very
big concessions
and then when donald trump took office
uh he ripped up the iran nuclear deal
he then murdered qasim soleimani who was
like
the national hero of iran um and then on
top of that we saw the assassination of
a very important iranian
nuclear scientist and so biden takes
office and he says
okay i'm open to renegotiating the iran
deal but
iran needs to make some concessions well
iran made huge concessions
and then got stabbed in the back so he
expects them to come back to the table
now and make even more concessions after
everything that's gone on
over the past four years uh and and now
we see this
strike which i must say the rhetoric
around this strike uh you know this
killing of iranians
in syria is is particularly shocking
because let's be real the iranians were
in syria to fight against
terrorism they were there to protect
christians from daesh
to fight against al-qaeda and al-nusra
to protect the secular
the syrian arab republic the secular
government that protects religious
minorities
but if you listen to american media you
would think that these iranians
that were in the country with the
permission of the internationally
recognized government you would think
that they were terrorists when they were
there
as part of an anti-terrorist operation
permitted by the government
meanwhile the u.s forces in syria have
absolutely no permission to be in the
country
they are clearly violating syria's
territorial
integrity they have no right to be there
uh donald trump said they were there to
take the oil and that's called
theft uh generally um so every
everything around this we've heard in
american media just completely gets
things wrong
yes you wonder if it's the stupidity of
the news media
or the venality of the news media
sometimes i think it might even be the
first
rather than the second but
in the case of saudi arabia
joe biden said that he would be
bypassing
the crown prince of saudi arabia and
dealing directly with his father
the king the problem is the king is too
old
and too ill even actually to speak
he cannot be talking directly to joe
biden because
he can't talk directly to anybody
so i thought well maybe this is the
beginning of
a distinct breakdown
in the very special relationship between
the united states and saudi arabia
maybe they'll be punished for their
crimes in yemen
maybe they'll have the weapons supplies
cut off maybe the crown prince will be
forced to pay for
the murder and dismemberment of
jamal khashoggi but none of these things
seems to be happening
indeed well it's important to note that
saudi arabia seems to be
in a bit of transition right because at
this point
the world and especially the united
states are not as dependent on them as
they once were with hydraulic fracking
uh the united states has quite a bit of
domestic oil
extraction that it that it can have it's
not completely dependent on the saudis
like they once were
and so saudi arabia it's also being
pointed out and you can see this in
documents from the atlantic council and
from the council on foreign relations
saudi arabia with its murderous war in
yemen is a huge
public relations disaster for the united
states of america the united states goes
around the world saying it loves
democracy
it loves freedom and it's backing a
country that still
chops people's heads off in public that
just recently legalized women driving
that is an unapologetic autocracy with a
king who
absolutely rules so uh it seems like
biden would like to distance the united
states from saudi arabia in the public
eye
but you'll notice that when he talked
about saudi arabia and their weapons
supply
what he said was he said we will no
longer be supplying saudi arabia with
offensive weapons but he said that they
would continue to help saudi arabia
quote
defend itself and they would be
providing them with defensive weapons
what's the difference between an
offensive gun and a defensive gun i
don't know the difference
this seems like some semantical word
play from the administration they're
trying to rescue the image of the united
states
but the reality is saudi arabia buys
huge
huge stockpiles of american-made weapons
uh
we they get satellite support in their
war on yemen
uh they have gotten the advising and the
uh the advisory support of pentagon
generals
and the united states is very very close
to saudi arabia
but you know let's be real jamal
khashoggi he worked for the washington
post which is owned by jeff bezos the
billionaire owner of amazon one of the
most rich and powerful men
in the united states and the killing of
jamal khashoggi was very much
an attack on the american establishment
it wasn't simply an attack on the
washington post or on jamal khashoggi
it kind of symbolized saudi arabia kind
of you know moving in its own direction
and
and kind of disrespecting the united
states it was an affront to the american
establishment and
as saudi arabia is in a state of crisis
uh you know
the the crown prince has carried out
kind of a crackdown on corruption in the
country
uh we've seen more centralization of
authority a lot of the
members of the royal family who got away
with all kinds of corrupt and nefarious
activities have been told they have to
cut it out as the country transitions
we continue to see the the crown prince
come out with these strange economic
plans for
changing the country involving flying
cars and robots and all kinds of you
know crazy stuff so
saudi arabia is in a bit of a crisis uh
the united states is in a bit of an
international
embarrassment in the way it deals with
saudi arabia all of this is a
narrow tightrope the biden
administration is trying to walk
but the reality is saudi arabia and the
united states are still
very very close as much as the theatrics
and the accusations and the words are
being exchanged
saudi arabia and the united states are
closer than ever now let's go back to
some of these extremely rich people i
learned
this week extraordinary uh numbers
uh from rt america that
in the last 50 years so from 1971
until now the top 1
of earners in the united states are 800
000 a year better off
while the average wage earner in the
united states
in the same 50 years is eight
thousand dollars better off in other
words
the gulf between the richest and the
average guy woman
in the street in the united states has
exponentially
increased if the democrats any plans to
tackle that he asked hopefully
well this is a continuation of policies
that have been enacted in the united
states for
decades and decades i mean you can go
back to the 1970s we have been seeing
the infrastructure of this country
falling apart
we've got many states around the country
that are that are unpaving the roads
because local municipalities cannot
afford to maintain
paved roads they're pulling up the
asphalt and pulverizing it and
where you used to have a paved road you
have a dirt road
we've got water treatment facilities
that are are not properly
operating and you know children drinking
poisonous water in places like flint but
many other parts of the country we have
problems purifying our water we saw in
texas
uh when you had the cold front you saw
the power grid of the state of texas
collapse and millions millions of people
left without electricity and
and then their pipes froze and it was
just just an infrastructural collapse
and
the average americans the working-class
communities that
are really the bulk of this country uh
have just seen their living standards
decrease
they've seen the good paying industrial
jobs eliminated
and all of this has just been escalated
by the pandemic you have to remember
that
walmart they are making out like bandits
during the pandemic
amazon is richer than ever because of
this pandemic but a lot of the small
businesses
a lot of the a lot of the communities
throughout this country uh they have
just been devastated
and we're seeing kind of a warfare
between the federal government and the
democrats
that are talking about you know keeping
the lockdown going and states like texas
and other states that are listed lifting
the mass mandate
and saying we need to just open up and
that is really a cry of desperation uh
the economy of so much of the
uh the the middle american bulk of
american you know you know communities
is just so
devastated amid this pandemic plus
decades and decades
of privatizations and neo-liberal
economic reforms and
this is this is the crisis this is the
story of the united states young people
stuck in
a cycle of low-wage short-term service
sector jobs
uh you know living standards decreasing
a rise in opioid addiction a rise in
suicide diseases of despair claiming
lives i mean the united states is
economically in quite a meltdown despite
the fact that we have the richest rich
people of any country in the world
no one disputes that the richest of the
rich in america are the richest in the
rich of the world
uh but but average americans have been
seeing their living standards go down
and down and down and the pandemic has
only exacerbated that
if the 41 billionaires in america
gave every american four thousand
dollars in relief
stimulus a check four thousand dollars
they would still be richer than they
were at the beginning of this pandemic
just think about that caleb
yes i mean it's there's no question
about it um you know the absence of any
economic discourse the fact that every
time
bernie sanders gets up and talks about
the need for maybe a national health
service or or you know
medicare for all uh the response to him
is people say well what about stalin i
mean that's just like stalin that's just
like pol pot that's just like mao i mean
the
the economic neoliberalism the idea that
we cannot
possibly have the state intervene to
take care of people economically that we
just have to have the government hands
off that's the american way
has been so ingrained in u.s society
over decades and decades and decades
the belief that any any attempt by the
state to fix up the economy is a an evil
marxist leninist conspiracy and that's
what we fought against in the cold war
blah blah blah
has been so ingrained among the
population that we've just seen
monstrous economic policies
that have just devastated the country
and the ultra rich have gotten richer
and richer and richer
but the very economic foundations of the
country the very infrastructure is just
falling apart as living standards
decrease
extraordinary finally and i'm grateful
for your time
the 15 dollar minimum wage
which would give the uh lowest paid
workers
30 000 a year for british people that's
i don't know 25 or 26 000
pounds a year is this now
dead as a dodo i think people will
continue to raise it uh it's something
that's very important in the democratic
camp uh there were many times that we
saw the democrats
be able to increase voter turnout by
actually putting
minimum wage initiatives on the ballot
and having
low-income workers basically go to the
polls to vote to increase their wages um
and so
i think in the democratic camp there
will still be talk of it um but it's
pretty clear however that among the
democratic leadership
there is an extreme amount of reluctance
to push
any reform of the minimum wage or
raising of the minimum wage at a federal
level that's very very clear
that the democratic leadership is not
interested in taking a federal move
however in local areas uh in different
states and municipalities
democrats have learned it's a very good
uh get out the vote mechanism so i think
we'll continue to see local
minimum wage initiatives uh for the
purpose of getting democrats elected
not any federal moves anytime soon caleb
mopan thanks for joining us
on the mother of all talk shows much
obliged to you sir
do you believe megan and harry have been
victimized by the queen
13 of you do but 58
of you don't and moreover 29
of you consider the pair to be publicity
hounds
that's on twitter on the telegram poll
on my telegram channel uh 12 percent of
you
more or less the same think they are
being victimized
53 percent of you think they are not
and 35 percent of you even more
on telegram consider them to be
publicity
hounds this is the mother of all talk
shows
let me give you the phone number because
uh you need to get your
calls in early because so many people
are disappointed
every week here's the number if you're
in the uk
02077-982-2555
and if you're in the us 001
757-744-4480
or you can tweet us at george galloway
at
rt uk news give me a two minute break
will you
radio sputnik
call me come and have a go if you think
you're hard enough
don't bring up a false name come on air
call me and let's have this mata out
[Applause]
that's 2016's argument michael i'm no
longer
arguing with you about the merits of
brexit
i'm arguing with you about democracy
about the right of the majority
to have their decision their vote
implemented this match will get red hot
not have a referendum and let them sort
it out among themselves
i want a want a reference
let me put that in capital letters if
you think this year
which is shaping up already to be an
honest
miserables for the snp if you think this
is your year go ahead come on
let's have it out
but no no george it's not as simple as
that right have you seen the documentary
about care image analytica and people
who work there
have you looked at this you know nothing
about that
i'm not interested in them bruce because
it's all a red herring
just like russia gay was a red herring
do you only want to hear voices that
agree
with you because if you do you're not
clever enough to be at this
open university of the airwaves in fact
you need to go back to remedial
and learn something about what democracy
and freedom of speech actually mean
tough questions are the most powerful
weapon we have
as long as you have questions we'll keep
asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
two 2069 votes in so far you've got
about an hour
to vote on the megan and harry uh
controversy uh not much change actually
in the
numbers that i gave you in the balance
of them
anyway uh i see the uh the
youtube comments are quite lively
tonight i really read comments
but there's no comments section like a
youtube
comment section believe me uh jonathan
i've done him
um marek says i wanted to wish them well
but i just knew she would be trouble
harry was a good lad before he met her
now he's under the thumb
he just does whatever she tells them
and headley says they are publicity
hounds
only in it for the money but teresa
says who gives us stuff about the royals
the sooner they're disbanded
the better say goodbye and give them a
house
in castle milk castle milk's a fine
place
for the royals to end up in well said
teresa now there is no
independent parliamentarian i like my
next guest
she is the epitome of an irish
independent parliamentarian for quite
some time she was in the irish
parliament itself in the doyle now she's
in the european parliament
and trust me she is the only person
worth watching
in the european parliament recently she
gave a round of the guns
uh at the russophobic
foaming at the mouth european
parliamentarians
and other ministers and in the
secretariat
who are pushing always always always for
more and more
hostile policies towards russia in the
european union i had her on sputnik
just the other day in which she
explained
in short order exactly what's going on
i'm glad to say she's now on the even
bigger stage
of the mother of all talk shows claire
derry
member of the european parliament
welcome
back to the mother of all talk shows now
claire
um just before we go on to the main
burden
of what we want you to talk about
tonight
have you ever been in a parliament more
dismal
than the european parliament yeah it's a
tough one i mean i've only been in two
parliaments so i haven't much to judge
from but out of the two
yes it'd probably be worse all right
than the irish one look at
there's a huge disconnect from the
european parliament with the citizens of
europe even worse
than it is in a lot of national
countries so
yeah you're probably probably know and
you're right it's just i was
wondering how uh a bird of paradise like
you
could function amongst the mundane
and the banal that that are
there largely on extremely low turnouts
of voters
second division third division uh
politicians
i i i feel for you i really feel for you
but
look clatten will get you everywhere
right and and thanks very much for all
the compliments but actually it's a kind
of a weird
bunch that's there i mean it is a
strange place there's no doubt about it
turnout is
incredibly low in a lot of the countries
but actually
i might agree with a lot of them but
some of them would be pretty capable you
have a lot of former ministers prime
ministers
army generals combined with sort of
ordinary activists as well so it's very
much a mixed bag but
sadly like a lot of other parliaments
it's pretty
disconnected from the people that it's
supposed to represent that's for sure
well you certainly don't waste your time
there every time i see you you
you are you are lashing them uh for
their political
uh errors and one of which i want to ask
you about now
i don't quite understand
the attitude of the european union
towards
russia after all germany has
just concluded despite brow beating and
belligerent
bullying and even bribery from the
united states
the nordstream ii pipeline so germany
and russia
are now inextricably linked presumably
forever
in the energy business
russia is the biggest european country
moscow the biggest european city
and yet all i hear out of the european
political scene is hostility towards
russia
i don't quite understand it
well i'm struggling to kind of deal with
myself to be honest
um i mean there's no doubt about it
you're right i mean there's been an
incredible
escalation i suppose in what we call the
new cold war rhetoric
with um european union parliamentarians
falling
over themselves to be the most critical
uh
of russia we saw that recently in the
visit of the high representative joseph
burrell to moscow where they were
calling for his resignation because he
had the audacity
uh to go on a visit but then on the
other hand you have a lot of
eu member states doing business with
russia so
i suppose for me the only thing that
will explain it is it's
hypocrisy they're playing a bit of a
game with the united states they're sort
of
um saying oh yeah russia can be our
bogeyman too it's convenient to target
russia
and particularly as they need to have a
justification for the ever increasing
amount of public money
that is going on militarism because it's
only now in the
recent budgets that for the first time
the european union is spending money
directly
on defense uh that's a departure uh as
an inconvenient time when we should be
spending money on health that we're
spending more on militarism but
you know if you're going to spend money
on armies and so on well then you have
to have
an enemy and uh certainly some of the
eastern european countries in particular
and others have decided that russia fits
the bill but i mean it's
pretty pathetic really do they drive it
do they drive it claire does russia's
near abroad
uh the former uh countries of the
warsaw pact are they driving this
uh anti-russian hostility the most
audible
champions of it in many ways but they
don't
carry enough clout for that on their own
i think it's a sort of desire to be
the best atlantis really you know it's
to curry favor with the united states
it's to keep in
the us's good books uh and it's to
respond to the call of the lobbyists who
uh occupy you know the the positions of
power really
in brussels they're the ones who call
the shouts so
they talk all the time about a security
threat we need to defend our borders
cyber security hybrid threats
foreign interference all of these good
stuff that they love talking about and
that they actually engage in themselves
but they do that to justify the big
contracts that big european money goes
for and the same
companies that benefit from the arms
contracts are the very ones that benefit
from the border security
and the surveillance contracts to keep
uh refugees out when they do engage
eventually and
in their wars to destabilize other parts
of the globe
very interesting now of course the
russians don't need the european union
russia has a very powerful economy
itself
and just as importantly has the closest
possible relations with china
which has very soon maybe by the end of
the night
will be the biggest economy in the world
and the russian attitude has been well
look we actually don't want anything to
do with the european union
we'll uh we'll deal directly with
european countries
but if the european union is going to be
so
vicious towards us we don't want
anything to
do with them does that play into the
borrow of the
of the russophobes in europe or does it
make them
uh maybe pause for thought
well i'd like to think it would but i i
think it would take more than that
i mean interestingly there's quite a lot
of negative rhetoric
uh also expressed towards the chinese
but interestingly in the last week or
two
china became the eu's biggest trading
partner but it doesn't stop them
um coming up with a lot of anti-chinese
rhetoric as well
um look at there's no doubt about
it business talks and the governments of
europe
are going to continue to do business
with russia we see that with germany in
particular
who are the ones who call the shots it's
interesting
that we hear a lot of talk from the
european commission about russian
disinformation around the vaccine but
yet european countries
are queuing up to seek and they get
access to the sputnik vaccine as well so
look at at the end of the day um there's
a little bit of melting off going on
here
it's it's regrettable because sadly
these things can
develop a life of their own and it's
very insulting really to the russian
people i
when i did have the chance to speak out
and try and have a little bit of balance
in the conversation i was really struck
by
the amount of europeans from across so
many different european countries and
irish people living in russia and so on
who said thanks a million
for trying to put a bit of balance here
and it just shows you
how much the conversation is tilted but
it's not tilted
in reality because you know as you say a
lot of the member states are doing
business with russia
and russia has said look we'll continue
to do business with them so as far as
i'm concerned it's the eu's loss really
uh russia doesn't need to worry about it
uh on julie and i'm sure there's rather
uh there's rather a good irish pub in
moscow which unlike the irish pubs in
ireland
is open for business uh and doing uh
doing a roaring trade finally speaking
of ireland
claire you must be in despair
at the performance of the new coalition
government in ireland which seems to be
making a mess of absolutely everything
it touches it is shocking
i mean it's really shocking like the
kind of nearly beginning to make the
european union look good maybe
not quite but um yeah they've been a
disaster i mean it's a coalition made up
of the two historical
right-wing parties with the green party
thrown in for
good measure and they're making a holy
show themselves
and they have made a disaster of covet
the economy is
shut down a year on and yet meat plants
are open and but yet children are not
going to school and there's chaotic
and contradictory health advice the
vaccine rollout
is all over the shop and uh
yeah they're an unmitigated disaster i
was in the irish parliament for eight
years
and i've never seen the likes of the
carry-on that's there at the moment and
it's so hard for
irish people who've suffered so much in
the course of the last year
to see this shambles um continue
it's it's appalling you might need to go
back there claire
and save them thanks for joining us on
the mother of
all talk shows claire daley independent
irish
member of the european parliament now dr
ranjit braar will be on an hour earlier
he's on just after the eight o'clock
news because after nine we've got the
right honourable norman
baker the former home office minister
and former lib dem member of parliament
and as some of you know he can't do
earlier than nine o'clock because he's
got his
own music radio show that he is doing
right at this minute so
if you have any calls on the coronavirus
issue get them in
right now especially if you want dr
ranjit
to deal with them dr ranjit brah coming
up
right after the news with jamie lowe
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
british prime minister boris johnson has
defended plans to give nhs staff in
england a 1 pay rise amid warnings that
nurses could quit
johnson said the government is giving
workers as much as we can
in the tough times of the covert
pandemic the rise which is less than
inflation
is being considered by an independent
panel and would cover
most hospital staff labour says the
proposal goes against a government
promise made last year
to give nhs workers a 2.1 pay rise
shadow health secretary jonathan
ashworth said chancellor rishi sunak had
been
cowardly when he sneaked out the
announcement a day after his budget
nurses have described the proposed pay
rise as insulting
with the union's threatening strike
action and warning what they call
the pitiful rise may lead to staff
quitting their jobs
worsening staffing issues in the health
service the royal college of nursing has
reiterated its calls for the government
to make a u-turn on the one percent
offer
and has set up a 35 million pound strike
fund
the uk must prepare for a hard winter
because the population
immunity to respiratory viruses other
than covid
could be lower than usual one of
england's top medics has said
dr susan hopkins said the nhs must be
ready for surges in flu
and other similar illnesses it comes
after england's first step towards
easing lockdown
with all pupils returning to school
tomorrow longer school days and shorter
holidays are among the measures the
government is considering to help pupils
in england catch up on lost learning
the education secretary has said gavin
williamson said ministers were looking
at how the school year
runs after the disruption of kovid he
also said a five-term
year and changes to summer holidays were
under consideration
the scottish conservatives say they will
push for a vote of no confidence in
snp minister john swinney on tuesday or
wednesday
leader douglas ross said he also wanted
to see a similar vote against first
minister nicolas sturgeon
unless further legal advice in the alex
salmon case were released
the scottish government published legal
advice related to its court battle with
the former deputy minister salman
this week deputy first minister swinney
had previously argued such advice should
remain
confidential but he then said he had
taken the exceptional step to rebuke
alleged false allegations made about the
scottish government's
legal advice over the judicial review
brought by salman
the move came after all opposition
parties indicated they were back a
motion of no confidence in swinney last
week if he did not comply
with the snp government facing defeat if
it goes ahead
pope francis is visiting parts of
northern iraq that were held by islamic
state militants on the third day
of his historic trip to the country
christians were among those targeted by
is when they seized the region in 2014
carrying out human rights abuses
the pope prayed among ruined churches in
mosul the former is stronghold before
meeting christians in karakosh
he also celebrated mass at a stadium in
irabil
with thousands of people attending
despite covert concerns
iraq which has seen more than 13 500
deaths with covert 19 and more than 726
000 cases has recorded a sharp increase
in infections over the past month
the 84 year old leader of the catholic
church and his entourage have all been
vaccinated
but iraq only received its first batch
of doses last week
china's foreign minister says
allegations his country is carrying out
genocide against muslim
ethnic uighurs are ridiculously absurd
and a complete lie
wang yi made the comments during his
annual news conference today
a number of nations including the us
have used the term to describe chinese
treatment of
uyghur people china has been accused of
carrying out forced
sterilization on uighur women and
separating children from their families
the united nations says at least one
million members of the muslim minority
are being held in the camps
which china says provide vocational
training and
are aimed at eradicating extremism
nazarene zagari ratcliffe the british
iranian woman jailed in iran on spying
charges has had her ankle tag removed
at the end of her five-year sentence
however her husband richard ratcliffe
has been told a new court case against
her is scheduled for next
sunday the charity worker had been under
house arrest in tehran
since being moved from jail last march
she's always denied the charges against
her the foreign secretary
dominic robb said she should be allowed
to return to the uk
the duke and duchess of sussex highly
anticipated tv interview with oprah
winfrey is set to air in the u.s later
tonight
it marks the first sit-down interview
with the couple since they quit their
roles as senior working royals last year
in a clip released earlier this week
megan said it was really liberating to
now feel able to speak for herself
the interview with oprah winfrey will
air in the u.s on cbs and the uk
on itv at 9pm tomorrow it comes as
buckingham palace is investigating
claims
the duchess bullied royal staff at
kensington palace
in reports about allegations of bullying
leveled at megan came after the
interview with oprah was recorded
megan has called it the latest attack on
her character in two clips released
earlier by cbs
megan said buckingham palace could not
expect her and prince harry to be silent
if it was perpetuating falsehoods about
them as she alleges
while harry drew parallels between the
treatment of his late mother
and finally a group of teachers have
filmed a parody video
ahead of the return of students to their
classrooms tomorrow
four teachers from the king's school in
rochester banded together for a lockdown
version of the 1995 take
that hit back for good it's sung by
school principal ben charles
head of the prep school tom morgan and
catherine openshaw headmistress
of the nursery and pre-prep school
chaplain father padfield also features
in the video the usual lyrics have been
changed to reflect the current pandemic
with the group
singing and i'm going to say that he's
not seeing them we'll be together
fingers crossed now for forever we'll be
fighting and forever we will be
so complete in our hope that we will
never be locked down again
let's see if the students take that to
number one in the charts but that is the
latest
here on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
do you believe that megan and harry have
been victimized by the queen yes
no or their publicity hounds you can
vote for the next
55 minutes on my twitter feed
coming up after the nine o'clock news
is the right honourable norman baker the
author
of how shall i put it a very
skeptical view of the british royal
family
in his book and what do you do he'll be
coming up after
nine which therefore explains
why moats medic dr ranjit brah
is with us an hour earlier and you could
tell it's an hour
earlier because his clock is working
and you can see it behind him there are
for those who are new to this there's a
multiple
set of conspiracy theories about the
fact that dr ranjit's
clock is sometimes not working and once
was thought to have disappeared
but it turned out to be behind his head
dr ranjit
thank you for joining us it's been
another good week
at least in britain on the coronavirus
front hasn't it
good to be with you george thank you and
it's lovely that my
clock is of such great such as such
great interest
um but yeah it has been uh we continue i
think you know really to be
on the road out of the pandemic
um in terms of numbers hospitalizations
um we've seen just over 40
000 test proven cases this week which is
a figure which is you know
reduced tenfold over a six week period
um deaths are still present and we're
still seeing people dying from
chronovirus but far
fewer that number is still 1
700 or just slightly more than that over
the past week
and again hospitalizations the number of
people we're seeing who are
in hospital with coronavirus uh has
fallen to
around twelve thousand twelve and a half
thousand
which corresponds to about twelve
percent of bed capacity whereas at its
peak uh we were looking at forty percent
of our bed capacity so
yeah not not going away but very much um
on the retreat and on the retreat
overwhelmingly due to
um yes the lock down but even more than
that the vaccination campaign where
we're getting on
uh two third of the population
who have been vaccinated and
increasingly uh you know
50 year olds and even four year olds and
people with slight medical problems
are being uh invited for vaccination
george
now this is the first job um
i said to uh a rather eminent
uh person on the phone the other night
uh
i'm so old i was vaccinated three weeks
ago
and they said i'm so old i've had both
my vaccinations
but the the efficacy of just the one
of the fisa has turned out to be
astoundingly
high hasn't it
it has and essentially it seems that the
um the initial studies published looked
at a certain time frame
they looked at three weeks um after the
second vaccination
which is also essentially six weeks
after the first vaccination but actually
if you just have the first vaccination
you look over at six
eight 12 weeks then actually the
your level of antibodies seem to
continue to rise even with a single
vaccination such that yes
we have seen you know in excess of
probably 80 percent
uh efficacy even with a single a single
jab so yeah that was um
it seemed like a gamble at the time but
it's the one that has certainly paid off
and is is very good news
for the number of people who've had
coverage and
how does that compare with the
european union because i ask because one
of the key
parts of project fear that was used
against brexit
was that we would be marooned
uh running out of medicines uh
apart from the sky going to fall in
planes going to fall from the
sky and all of that but they
particularly honed in
on the fact that your old mother
wouldn't be able to get our medicine and
so on
that looks all very hollow now
it does the eu obviously has an enormous
population
around 400 million however
uh the last figures i saw seemed to show
that around only five
to six percent of the population the eu
uh had been
vaccinated so quite a low figure and
they're still involved in various spats
just as them
they were very upset that there was a
delay in astrazeneca delivering them
vaccine and they threatened to retaliate
really with the trade embargo trade
trade measures trade sanctions against
the uk saying that they were going to
prevent the fisa biantec vaccine from
being
exported from germany to us and they've
had a recent similar spat with uh
australia where first italy and now
france it seems also
are likely to prevent um promised doses
of vaccine going from the eu
to australia so putting a lot of strain
on there on their relations over this
over this question and showing you know
as the hungarian
um prime minister said um
many months ago towards the beginning of
this crisis it shows you the extent of
european solidarity that when the heat
is on
um it's every man for themselves and the
idea of europe or the eu being some
happy family
has been really put to the test by this
situation and we know for example
again hungary uh czech republic uh other
countries have been seeking urgently and
and some of them have in fact given a
vac
an emergency license uh to get the
russian sputnik vaccine whereas the eu
overall still has not
done so that did make some noises that
it might
the britain has vaccinated
a greater percentage of our population
than germany france italy and spain
put together that's a pretty remarkable
statistic
yeah it is i think you know we have um
we are
we've got an excess number of doses in
terms of those that we bought
as we get towards vaccinating the
vulnerable of the
population um you know really i i do
think there's going to be a question as
to
whether the vaccination program needs to
continue we we have done well but so
there will be a large number of people
from the
relatively uh you know less vulnerable
population who still
don't really want to take the vaccine
that was open to question whether we
need to vaccinate children uh you know
my personal view is that
you know people under under 18 probably
don't need to take the vaccine
i haven't seen final plans as to whether
they offered it and people of course
who've
had um the coronavirus wonder whether or
not they need to take it there's no harm
in taking it but
equally they get equal protection um
just from having had
the the uh the chronovirus itself but um
yeah
so essentially our program has gone well
and i do feel like you know over the
next
couple of months this we should be
looking at the at the end
of this pandemic effectively for the
population here george
now uh we've done very well on
vaccination but we did catastrophically
badly
in the pre-vaccination period
and we seem to have snatched
uh defeat from the jaws of victory when
it comes to
how we treat the workers in the national
health service
it doesn't seem that long ago that
everyone was out
clapping them on a thursday evening
but the government have just clapped
them in the face
by offering them a one percent wage
increase
what do you say to that yeah i i
entirely agree george it seems
um not only counter-intuitive but it's
uh
it's it's it's an insult particularly to
that i mean to the whole of the medical
profession actually
nurses doctors um you know
physiotherapists radiographers
occupational therapists all of the nhs
employees of course so many of our
nhs staff in terms of cooks in terms of
cleaners
in terms of ground staff are in fact
already privatized out
and subcontracted so that there's a huge
number of people who work in hospitals
who aren't
um you know nhs employees and won't get
any pay rise
but those who are direct core employees
and even
increasing number of those are bank
staff of various kinds
but yes to have such a low pay rise when
we know that wages are at a historic low
actually if you look at them
i was involved in 2016 in the junior
doctor's
contract dispute the new contra pac did
go through in the end and that was
essentially a 40 percent
pay cut for doctors that's what it meant
as well as a decrease in their ability
to whistle blow
a decrease in their employment terms and
many doctors left the profession over
that
nurses of course have a considerably
lower
income and they've not been isolated but
several
documented instances of nurses whose
wages are so low
that they're really struggling to
commute into work get home to work
and and feed um their families
on their wage having to visit food banks
these are not spurious accounts these
are
documented accounts so that we have an
incredibly hard-working
uh part of our population who give such
a key service that we're all dependent
on that we've witnessed
the importance of their work witnessed
it afresh and anew
throughout this pandemic and then to
offer them what is effectively a pay
cut um is you know
is is frankly disgusting george and it's
widely felt to be so
i think throughout the british
population and particularly throughout
the working-class population of britain
now maureen in texas is on the line for
you doctor let's hear what she
wants to ask maureen welcome to the show
maureen yes
yes go ahead maureen the doctor's
waiting
yes hello i'm calling from
texas and i have a question about
the modern vaccine
i am a health care provider oh sorry i
am a healthcare provider and i work with
covid patients and i received the first
dose of the vaccine at the end of
december
and however my employer refused to give
me the second dose
and i've been unable to locate
a place to re to get it on my own
and is there any data as far as if i'm
given any protection by just one single
dose and if i
am able to locate a place willing to
give me the vaccine
should i just start over as if i was not
vaccinated
at all or just get the second one as i
should have good question
good question maureen in texas doctor do
you know the answer
well thanks maureen and i really totally
understand your
concern so particularly when there was
um the question here in this country we
haven't had the modern
virus a vaccine we've had the um
astrazeneca and the pfizer biotech the
physic and the
madonna work on a similar technology and
i would
suspect that they're likely to behave in
similar ways and therefore i suspect
that you're likely to get
substantial immunity even from a single
dose but the companies you know um
haven't fully either of those companies
with the mrna viruses vaccines
have not fully published all of their
data um
we are going on the first interim
analyses of their randomized controlled
trials
and they neither company have um
accepted the recommendation for a single
dose even in the face now quite a lot of
evidence
in the case of uh pfizer biotech then in
fact it is effective so
i understand your concern i think you
are likely to be have a fair degree of
protection particularly as time
continues three four five
six weeks um you'll have a considerable
amount of protection
i i haven't seen any studies relating to
the uh that particular company and that
particular vaccine
on a single dose protocol and if you can
get the second dose then absolutely
i would go ahead and try and secure it
maureen
why are they refusing to give you the
second one
it was a situation where i was a
contract employee
and because my contract ended the very
week that
it was due they
abruptly refused to give it to me saying
that they were reserving it for their
regular
full-time employees seems
extraordinarily mean modern thanks i
hope the
answer gave you some solace some comfort
let's go to stewart in halifax go ahead
stewart
good evening george uh good evening
doctor um
my question is i've already had the
first of the astrazeneca vaccines
i i have ms multiple sclerosis
and i've had a relapse with my multiple
sclerosis
since i've had the vaccine it's been two
weeks now and i've had 10 days of
relapse
my question for you dr angie was
um would you still advise me to have the
second
job bearing in mind that i've had a a
considerable relapse from the first one
wow that's a big question uh stewart um
doctor do you want to have a try
answering that
yeah i'm so sorry to hear that you've
obviously had had to relax how
um how often is it relapsing and
remitting your or your ms
that's what i was initially diagnosed
with but i am in the process of having
further diagnosis because
they can't quite put the finger on which
category
that i'm in um of course
i can only you know you have a real
sympathy i'm so sorry you had this
relapses
it's a very difficult condition
unpredictable condition to live with
and i'm i'm not a neurologist i don't
want to give you specialist advice in
your field of
neurology i haven't seen any document um
or any indication and i've looked at
the kind of the yellow card reporting
data for for the vaccines
that we're using in england and i
haven't seen any um relationship
put forward between the vaccine and
and ms or relapsing and or you know
a relapse of ms of multiple sclerosis so
it's something that i don't know the
answer to i don't know if anyone would
know the answer to
i think there's no proven relationship
based on the data that is
available and i personally don't think
it would be a reason
not to have the second dose i would tend
to go ahead and have the second dose but
i would probably
in your instance ask the advice of your
specialist your neurologist and whether
they have any further insight or
opinion on that before you go ahead and
do so quite important
stuart i think that you do that uh
because obviously
we don't know you we can't see you the
doctor uh can't give out uh
you know advice in a field that isn't
his uh
so it is quite important that you
consult your neurologist
last one do you stuart um yeah i've
spoken to my ms nurse
and um a few of her patients i have a
specialist nurse
a few other patients are reporting
um relapses after having
both pfizer or the astrological vaccine
thankfully most of them are short-lived
and and are resolving um so yeah the
little bit of advice i've had so far was
what prompted my call to yourselves and
just to
a bit of an insight for anybody else who
might be suffering as well if they are
having something up to the job that yes
to speak to the specialists
my new real surgeons yeah i've got two
of those i have one
uh a private one and a public one a
the the private one again something that
i would want to discuss with yourselves
was the benefits of the medical cannabis
registry which i am on at the moment and
that does seem to be having
an impact and i think maybe something
that we need to speak about
a little bit more going forward um
there there is a big push
to treat people with medicinal cannabis
for
certain disorders so thank you i promise
you
we will we will come back to that uh and
i
i really hope that you're uh that your
health picks up and that this
uh is only a short term uh relapse that
you are suffering thanks very much
indeed for that call thank you doctor
as always for helping us through the
latest stage in this
very very long and difficult saga much
obliged to you
dr ranjit brah uh the poll is uh doing
uh great numbers 2490 people
have voted you've still got about half
an hour to get your vote in on
my twitter feed 60 second break
count them radio sputnik
[Music]
in a media landscape filled with
so-called journalists acting as
stenographers for their billionaire
bosses
there is a desperate need for news
analysis and perspectives that bug the
status quo
and get to the heart of how domestic and
international events
impact you and me as well as showing how
we can get involved in the struggle
to change that status quo check out by
any means necessary on radio sputnik
monday through friday from 2 to 4 p.m
eastern to hear the stories and voices
that mainstream media refuses to tell
you
and join us as we connect the political
social and economic
movements shaping the world around us
that's by any means necessary
monday through friday at 2-4 pm eastern
right here
on radio sputnik
hello pizza express woking
what is it you want oh you want an
ill-advised interview on the bbc
a cheese pizza extra immature and a
rural bailout
no we don't take taxpayers money yeah
but we do take contactless
would you like a receipt for that mr
prince
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends
contributors and callers everyone is
welcome
now this is where i look back and
occasionally askance
at seven momentous days in our history
this is
the week this was the day in 1965 when
state troopers and volunteer officers
attacked black and white protesters in
selma
alabama injuring at least 50 people they
waded into a group of about 500
demonstrators using tear gas whips and
sticks after governor george wallace
remember him
ordered the planned march from selma to
the state capital montgomery
to be halted on the grounds of public
safety
the violent scenes in selma left 17
people
in hospital and came to be known as
bloody sunday yes
another bloody sunday civil rights
leader dr
martin luther king then organized
another march there
two days later his group knelt
and prayed in front of the state
troopers
who stopped them at the edmund pettus
bridge but did not attack them
presumably because the whole world was
watching
president lyndon b johnson finally
signed
a new voting rights act almost six
months later
in august 1965 that banned
discrimination
in voting practices and procedures on
the grounds of race or
color that'll be great when it finally
comes
in in 1969 golda meir
the so-called grand old woman of israeli
politics
was elected as the first female prime
minister
of israel she was 70. now i'm not yet 70
so maybe there's hope
for me yet now in this week in 1956
britain ordered the deportation of the
greek cypriot leader
archbishop macarios in the forlorn hope
of restoring law and order
to the crown colony the the archbishop
was arrested
when he arrived at nicosia airport to
board an
airliner for athens pardon me
after refusing to denounce the use of
violence
britain accused him of quote actively
fostering terrorism
he was deported to the seychelles now if
you're going to be deported then
the seychelles isn't a bad place to be
deported too
the following day though riots broke out
in cyprus
the united states and greece condemned
the british government's decision
and there were even objections from the
labour party and no
i'm not making that up you certainly
wouldn't get that today from the present
lot
macarios was allowed to return to cyprus
when he finally gave up hope of enosis
or unification with greece he received a
tumultuous welcome
when he returned in 1959 and later that
year
he became president and in 1960
cyprus became independent
joseph stalin's daughter svetlana
requested political asylum
at the united states embassy in india
in 1967. she later
denounced her father eventually becoming
a u.s citizen well it's kind of
conditionality wrote a book and then
disappeared into well-deserved
obscurity in 1969
james earl ray was jailed for 99 years
by a court in memphis tennessee after
admitting he carried out the murder
of the american civil rights leader the
aforementioned
reverend dr martin luther king his
guilty plea was made on the
understanding that he was
spared the electric chair it also
brought a swift end to the trial
three days after his jailing though ray
recanted his guilty plea he claimed
he'd been set up by a gun dealer in
montreal
known only as raul as you do he spent
the next 29 years
fighting for the trial that his own
guilty plea
had forestalled and he won the support
of the king
family ray died in april 1998.
now if you believe that james already
was the only
lone gunman involved in the murder of
martin luther king
i have a rather fine bridge here in
london
that i could sell you a court in the
iraqi capital baghdad
imposed a sentence of death on the
observer journalist
farzad bazoft in 1990
he was convicted of spying for israel
while working on a story about an
explosion
at a weapons complex 30 miles south of
the capital
international appeals for clemency fell
on deaf ears
and bazoft was hanged on the 15th of
march
1990. there was a new man in charge at
the kremlin this week
in 1985 mikhail gorbachev took over
barely 24 hours after the death
of constantine chernienko the speed of
naming of his successor
at 54 the youngest man to take over
as general secretary of the soviet
communist party
took people by surprise gorbachev
radically changed the course of soviet
foreign policy
signing a number of agreements with the
united states
on nuclear disarmament he introduced a
policy of
openness or glasnost and he was also the
architect of perestroika
or deep political and economic reforms
but his reforms led to severe economic
hardship at home
growing nationalist movements
spearheaded by the baltic states
led him to propose a loose federation
of soviet states and this proved the
last straw
for his opponents in august 1991
he survived a coup attempt largely
thanks to the support
of the russian authorities under the
then leadership of boris yeltsin
who was just sober enough to climb onto
a tank for the cameras
one of the most influential men of all
time
died in 1955 and he was
a scotsman alexander fleming who
discovered the life-saving drug
penicillin purely by accident
he had been on holiday and returned to
his laboratory
to discover mold on one of the
experimental dishes
on which he had been curing culturing
rather
bacteria rather than washing the dish he
noticed that the mold
had killed the bacteria surrounding it
what at first he called mold juice
became penicillin
the discovery of penicillin transformed
the world of
medicine it was the first antibiotic
drug without it many illnesses would be
incurable and life expectancy would be
lower now no one can be accurate about
it but medical
scientists estimate that this fortunate
mistake by alexander fleming the
scotsman
may have saved 200 million
lives since 100
people died and at least 1800 were
injured
as huge explosions tore through three
madrid train stations during a morning
rush hour
in this week in 2004.
spanish government of the time pretended
that the
basque group etta were the prime
suspects
although they knew differently the day
after the blasts and
arabic tape with quranic quotes was
found
in a suspect van near madrid at least
one group
claiming links to al qaeda said it
planted
the bombs this was the week in 1984
that tens of thousands of britain's
miners
stopped work in what became a year-long
battle
against job losses the strike only began
to crumble
when the national coal board offered
miners various pay incentives
to return to work before christmas
i have been an honorary member of the
national union of mineworkers
since 1982 and that
mine workers union card is one of my
proudest
possessions on a happier note pun
intended the beatle paul mccartney
married linda
eastman in a civil ceremony in london in
hundreds of people gathered outside the
marleybone registry
office to catch a glimpse of the couple
as they arrived with eastman's
six-year-old daughter
heather from a previous marriage linda
died of breast cancer
in 1998 at the mccartney ranch
in tucson arizona mccartney is still
churning out the music and still getting
married
at the malibun registry office i know
that because
i saw his marriage on the steps
of the marleybone registry office the
wife that he is still married to at
least
i hope so and finally on the 13th of
march
in 1996 my goodness thomas hamilton
scraped ice off the window of his van
before setting off
indiscriminately to murder children at a
primary school
in dunblane in scotland he sprayed shots
at random
around the school gym in an attack that
lasted just three minutes
but caused carnage in a class of five
and six year olds when he stopped firing
16 children and their teacher were dead
and 15 more children were wounded
he then turned the gun on himself andy
murray who grew up to be the
champion tennis player was in the next
class
scheduled to go into the gym he
sheltered throughout
in the headmaster's office hamilton had
licenses
for six guns leading to criticism of the
police
for not questioning what he used them
for
a massive campaign was launched after
the dunblane massacre
for tighter gun controls the snowdrop
campaign
was successful in achieving a change in
the law
in 1997 making it illegal
to buy or possess a handgun
that's in britain of course in the
united states rather different laws
apply it's a somber and shocking quota
to this seven days in our history that
was the week that was now let's go to
the lines
uh lots of calls uh lined up sarcar
is in glasgow go ahead sarkar
hi george uh good evening how are you
keeping by the grace of god i'm good
thank you very much go ahead
thank you george first of all all the
best for the scottish elections and i'm
very happy to see how you've been
promoting the tactical voting and the
constituency voting i really appreciate
that george thank you uh
george small question basically labour
party and the kiosk armor was supposedly
going in a new direction because
everything which went wrong in labor was
put down on jeremy corbyn
supposedly the man was everything which
was the reason because labor lost
they said that britain cannot be having
a left-wing leader okay here comes kia
starmer
he's behind 15 points or 20 points out
in the opinion polling
i don't see him coming up with any new
ideas i personally don't know what he
stands for
and nowadays the left or the so-called
champions of the working class
are more interested in identity politics
whether fireman sam should be of this
gender
potato head should be a bad gender when
will we have a true
champion who knows how to talk for the
people like a barbara castle or a tony
ben
that's my question it's a brilliant uh
question
the labour party's leader is a block of
wood
no ideas will be forthcoming from him
and i think that moves will begin
shortly
to remove him the skids are under him
but they are profoundly
under the party as a whole you cannot
successfully compete for power
in a country where a very large number
of the people in that country
believe that you hate them that you hate
the way they
live the way they think the way they
talk
and the kind of ways in which they want
to live their lives
their cultural norms their
belief in family their belief that men
are men and women are women
their belief in their flag in their
armed forces
if you are a party that seems
and goes out of its way to see to hate
all these things well by definition
you're hating the
people uh who believe in those things
and
they're not going to vote for you now
labor has been on that course
for a very long time it reached its
apogee over the brexit
issue where notwithstanding that the
clear majority had voted for brexit
labor lent itself to withering fire
on the people who had thus voted and
called them all kinds of
nasty names and acted as if they were
something distasteful that the cat
had dragged in the
labour front bench spokesman who just
two weeks ago
suggested that we should drop mr mrs
miss in favor of mx
and my this kind of madness this kind of
identity politics madness has done
for the labour party amongst
working-class people
and you'll have heard me say earlier in
the latest opinion poll
that puts labor 13 points behind
boris johnson amongst working class
people
it was two to one double the number of
supported the tories as supported
labor this is fatal this is terminal
and rightly so because the truth is
labor's obsession with
race with sexual identity
with gender uh with identity politics of
all kinds these people
are obsessed by these things for a
reason
not just because they are overwhelmingly
university educated middle class student
union political types
but because the more you talk about
these things
the less you have to talk about the big
things the things that really
matter who whom who owns britain
for whom who exercises power in this
country
about class about the vast
gulf in uh earnings and wealth
in this country these are the things
labor
doesn't want to talk about so it talks
about
other things instead it talks about
whether
potato head should be called mr
potato head even though by the way
there's a mrs
potato head she must be very confused
that her husband
can no longer be called mr potato head
that obsesses about whether farm and sam
is too white too pale
too male too straight to be allowed
to be played with uh by our children and
watched on the
children's television channels this kind
of liberal identity politics
madness which began in the united states
but which came here at least 40 years
ago and i saw it happening in front of
my
eyes as a labor uh figure
at that time as a labor member of
parliament
at that time i saw it happen sliced by
slice by slice and the so-called left
in the labor party are the biggest
culprits
and now this is where it has all
ended what britain needs and what
america needs is a party
that will allow people to live the lives
they want to
lead to call each other mr and mrs
if they choose to to call people
their wife or their husband if they
choose to to leave issues
that will divide the working class at
the door
and concentrate on uniting the working
class that's the politics i believe in i
also happen to believe it's the politics
that will
repay in terms of votes
and electoral and political support
i'm supremely uninterested
in people's sexual orientations
or what gender they think they are
each to their own if you turn up
in a cocktail dress but with a beard
and tell me you're a woman i'll give you
a hug and a kiss
and call you madam i don't care
about your outward persona
i don't care about your inner angst
i care about your relationship to
wealth and power i'm ready to stand
with you as a worker
whatever you're wearing whatever color
you are
however you pray wherever you came from
you get me sarkar that's the politics
not only that i believe in
but it's the politics that we try to
practice
and i believe it's the politics of the
future
people are sick of being called ists
and obs and insulted as
sexist misogynist transphobic and all
the other
epithets that are hurled up people
we care nothing for these things
we believe the world is divided between
the have-nots
and the have yachts and it's about time
they have not
got together to take their share here's
fred the red
in buxton go ahead fred
nice to meet you nice name
yeah and a fine result in manchester
oh dear i was not expecting it fred were
you
no i was terrified but elated at the
at the final whistle fantastic shaw was
the man of the match for me
absolutely unbelievable best fall back
in europe
and it's not the first time i've said
he's the man of the match he's having a
fantastic yeah excuse
me anyway george i think i'm odd enough
so i've come to have a little go
okay go ahead uh the tinfoil hat wearing
internet researchers that you keep
having a go at
yeah yes uh well
i'm warming up fred
well there's a lot of um conspiracy
theories that have become
conspiracy facts yeah sure to the
internet well i spoke about one of them
earlier about uh uh james l ray and the
mother absolutely yeah but i just
realized
a couple of biggies yeah mk ultra
remind us what that is uh lsd
bumped into new york
um underground by the cia
wow read up on it george it's a fight i
have heard that yeah it was nothing yeah
nothing the cia could do
would surprise me fred it's not that i
don't believe there are conspiracies in
the world
there are myriad conspiracies absolutely
it just doesn't mean that everything is
therefore
a conspiracy no absolutely
selective yeah fred i was there i would
also say that you know working people
don't have the time that you have to
research things
and the internet is very convenient very
fast
i wish i had a lot of time fred i was
just going to say
i spent nearly 30 years sitting in the
building along the road there
i know that a lot of things are cock-ups
not conspiracies because we're ruled
by austin powers not by james bonds
yeah yeah i get that but where would
vanessa beely
eva bartlett robert fisk
be without the internet i'm not against
the internet fred i don't know where you
got the idea i was against the internet
well
no i know you're not against the
internet but it's people that research
on the internet that you were on
occasion called
tin foil hat wearers yeah and i get i
get that only if what they then come out
with is worthy of that that
that nomenclature not everything that's
researched on the internet
is of course crazy of course it isn't
no but it it's a very convenient way for
ordinary people to get information and
you have to be selective i'll give you
that
but you know don't write them all off as
tim
but if they come out with nonsense i
have a duty to
call it nonsense whether you've got it
from yeah that's quite true
that's why i have my george more likely
internet it's just i think i now know
what you mean
when people call me up and say i've been
doing my research
and it turns out that they've looked on
the internet
not everybody who says that is nuts but
everybody who is nuts
does say that yes yes i'll give you that
one
okay fred there was nothing you would be
very dappers we were friends you
even support the same football team last
last word to you
looking very dapper tonight george thank
you thank you john
my wife turns me out well thanks very
much fred the red
in buxton let me take a quick break
well um how did i do i'm sorry prime
minister
at no point did you drive on the
left-hand side of the road
and instead of driving us forward she
made several u-turns
we haven't gone anywhere i think you'll
find
if you turn backwards uh enough times
eventually
you'll go forward so uh did i pass
no you failed miserably but my teachers
said i'd get much higher grades
better look next time this doesn't
happen
to people like me
you leave me no choice
i'm sorry but rules are rules even for
prime ministers
what's on earth is that my mutant
pets dominic cummings
no big algorithm
get it
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
[Music]
now i think the poll is about to close
so i should tell
you the only 13 percent of you think
that megan
and harry who turn out to be a duke and
a duchess
actually i'm i'm reliably informed and
corrected
rather than the princess that i called
earlier
she ain't no princess guff anyway do you
believe megan and harry have been
victimized by the queen
only 13 of you say yes 59
of you say no and a further 28 percent
of you
denounced the pair as publicity hounds
almost
3 000 people voted in that poll you've
got a few minutes left
i think but only a very few
now some social media because i'm not
doing justice
to the social media people daphne says
harry carries within him the experience
of his mother's
final few years so it's inevitable that
he would wish to remove his family
from that anxiety the public loves
salacious gossip so why shouldn't the
couple take advantage of that
via the sympathetic ear of
oprah i hear a band playing daphne uh
prince william of course he had a mother
also the same mother and the same
experience
of the last few years but i saw him
uh on television recently in a program i
wouldn't normally have watched i trust
you
trust me i'm not remotely interested in
royals
but prince william was on with some
football people talking about depression
amongst men and he enormously
impressed me i must say not just with
the
his sympathetic ear but with his
gift for finding the right words and the
right encouragement
to people men who are suffering usually
in silence
from depression and as someone who
doesn't
care about royals and has never been
depressed
i stayed with that program throughout
its
entirety and so that's a tribute to
his ability grace says i wonder how much
the interview is worth
to the sympathetic opera yes a very good
point grace
if they're getting 10 million for it
imagine how much she's making
and marie says got to wonder how their
two children will
end up these two are insufferable and
steve says megan thought
she would be a hollywood princess got
shocked when it involved
work and the press were interested in
her past
interested in how she cut people who
couldn't further her career
out of her life and then suddenly she
wanted
privacy and gideon says i can't think
what has possessed harry to squander the
huge
goodwill and positive sentiment felt by
most of us
towards him i hope in the end he feels
the filthy looker was worth it the light
i kept in the window
for harry and megan is now to be
extinguished
i doubt if he's doing it for the money
she might well be
um i don't think that it's
money for him i think he has fallen
under her spell i'm sorry if that sounds
sexist but i have known men
that have been so infatuated be sorted
by their glamorous partners
that they ended up being led by the nose
by that partner now that may be
completely
off beam but i don't think harry
is doing it for the money i think he's
doing it for
the love of megan and
i also have perhaps a mean
suspicion that some way down the road
he'll realize that and regret it
maybe i'm right maybe i'm wrong what do
i know peter is in london
and he's on the line go ahead peter
hello george um you join your program
very much
thank you i just wanted to say at the at
the opening there
where you said labour party members
should leave the party yeah
uh basically i fundamentally disagree
with what you're saying there
um well i think in our system where you
have first pass opposed
inevitably we're going to have two large
parties which are both going to be
broad church and if you're on the left
in any
in in any way you need to be on the
the left party and that's where the
fight has to has to take place
um but you already had that fight and
won it peter and now you've lost it and
you'll never win it again
well that's what you think george but uh
no that's what that's what
kierstarma thinks they have changed
they've changed the rules so that you
can never win it again
don't you see i i i
he may have changed the rules for now
but we changed the rules before
things can change and and if you're
going to be realistic about getting
power in this country as it is at the
moment
but how much better can you do peter
than having jeremy corbyn as your leader
having a left but it didn't work
well it didn't work uh it was a it was a
great opportunity
he brought hundreds of thousands of uh
people into the party
where are they then starmer won the
election
out of the park well a lot of people
voted
on the left voted for starmer
[Music]
well they were left they were left but
they believed that
he would bring the party together he
made loads of players
then no they're not idiots they're
genuine people
who who wanted to see a change uh and
wanted to see the
the labour party democratized and um
unfortunately uh they feel let down by
kirsten and they've left but
some of them have stayed and we're still
there and we're still fighting
when you say fighting you mean you're
fighting against other people in your
own party
well yeah to be brutally honest that is
going on yes of course
so yes um when do you get around to
starting
fighting for for socialism
uh against the tories and amongst the
public
well that goes on at the same time we
argue our points uh
locally but it's a very very difficult
time
peter is it because if starmar imposes
as he has
imposed uh highly centralized control
now that he completely controls the
whole show
you'll be going out for example in
london
uh urging people to vote not for
socialism but for sadiq khan
well we have to argue for that yes at
the moment i mean how is that
fighting for socialism well it's a lot
it is a long
it you've got to take the long picture
how long are you going to live 200 years
uh peter you're going to spend the rest
of your life
arguing for people to vote for a series
of men and women that hate you
that would rather you left and who stand
for
quite different things to what you stand
well i think there's as i say it's a
broad church
to me how broad is it peter there's
never going to be
there's no left people
going to be allowed to be candidates
there's no left policies going to be
allowed to be
fought for okay george if
well at the moment that is not a good
time i i completely agree
so how bad does it need to get before
you say
actually this is to help with this for a
game of soldier
well i look at it realistically and i
see how where the power lies in this
country
yeah which i think is a you know that's
a good thing but
you'll only have power in this system if
you take a lot of members with you
and also also the big year
for the power peter i'm not enough for
the power
but i don't have to i don't have to wake
up in the morning
and fight somebody else in my own party
for the next decade two decades
three decades until i'm dead that is i
promise you
much better for your soul
um now here's my my last point because i
need to go to the news in a minute
my last question to you is this
you are in a party that has
kicked out your former leader
he was 12 months ago the leader now
he's kicked out but you're staying
in i'm there for the moment he's still
in the party he's had the whip removed
that fight hasn't been
fought he's not a labour mp he's not a
labour employee
the leader of the labour party a year
ago
is now not a labour mp
how much worse does it need to get peter
well you could only fight it
inside you can't fight it outside what
forever
in all seconds is it a religion
no it's not a religion but i i look at
the system we have uh
this is where the fight is in the labour
party it's not
they won't have you back unfortunately i
know that but
not only wouldn't they but i would
sooner
gouge out my eyes here in front of the
audience
with a teaspoon then join
the labor party trust me it will
there will be a murder peter if i went
back
into the labor party anyway it's been a
pleasure disagreeing with you
thanks very much for the call here's the
news
with jamie law
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for free radio sputnik
we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news
british prime minister boris johnson has
defended plans to give nhs staff in
england a 1 pay rise amid warnings that
nurses could quit
johnson said the government is giving
workers as much as we can
in the tough times of the covert
pandemic the rise which is less than
inflation
is being considered by an independent
panel and would cover
most hospital staff labor says the
proposal goes against a government
promise made last year
to give nhs workers a 2.1 pay rise
shadow health secretary jonathan
ashworth said chancellor rishi sunak had
been
cowardly when he sneaked out the
announcement a day after his budget
nurses have described the proposed pay
rise as insulting
with the union's threatening strike
action and warning what they call
the pitiful rise may lead to staff
quitting their jobs
worsening staffing issues in the health
service the royal college of nursing
has reiterated its calls for the
government to make a u-turn on the one
percent offer
and has set up a 35 million pound strike
fund
the uk must prepare for a hard winter
because the population
immunity to respiratory viruses other
than covid
could be lower than usual one of
england's top medics has said
dr susan hopkins said the nhs must be
ready for surges in flu
and other similar illnesses it comes
after england's first step towards
easing lockdown
with all pupils returning to school
tomorrow longer school days and shorter
holidays are among the measures the
government is considering to help pupils
in england catch up on lost learning
the education secretary has said gavin
williamson said ministers were looking
at how the school year runs after the
disruption of covid
he also said a five-term year and
changes to summer holidays were under
consideration
the scottish conservatives say they will
push for a vote of no confidence in
snp minister john swinney on tuesday or
wednesday
leader douglas ross said he also wanted
to see a similar vote against first
minister nicolas sturgeon
unless further legal advice in the alex
salmon case were released
the scottish government published legal
advice related to its court battle with
the former deputy minister salman
this week deputy first minister swinney
had previously argued such advice should
remain
confidential but he then said he had
taken the exceptional step to rebuke
alleged false allegations
made about the scottish government's
legal advice over the judicial review
brought by salman
the move came after all opposition
parties indicated they were back a
motion of no confidence in swinney last
week if he did not comply
with the snp government facing defeat if
it goes ahead
pope francis is visiting parts of
northern iraq that were held by islamic
state militants
on the third day of his historic trip to
the country
christians were among those targeted by
is when they seized the region in 2014
carrying out human rights abuses
the pope prayed among ruined churches in
mosul the former is stronghold before
meeting christians in karakosh
he also celebrated massada stadium in
irabil
with thousands of people attending
despite covert concerns
iraq which has seen more than thirteen
thousand five hundred deaths with covert
19 and more than 726
000 cases has recorded a sharp increase
in infections over the past month
the 84 year old leader of the catholic
church and his entourage have all been
vaccinated
but iraq only received its first batch
of doses last week
china's foreign minister says
allegations his country is carrying out
genocide against muslim ethnic
uighurs are ridiculously absurd and a
complete lie
wang yi made the comments during his
annual news conference today
a number of nations including the us
have used the term to describe chinese
treatment of
uyghur people china has been accused of
carrying out forced
sterilization on uiga women and
separating children from their families
the united nations says at least one
million members of the muslim minority
are being held in the camps
which china says provide vocational
training and
are aimed at eradicating extremism
nazanin zagari ratcliffe the british
iranian woman jailed in iran on spying
charges has had her ankle tag removed
at the end of her five-year sentence
however her husband richard ratcliffe
has been told a new court case against
her is scheduled for next
sunday the charity worker had been under
house arrest in tehran
since being moved from jail last march
she's always denied
the charges against her the foreign
secretary dominic robb
said she should be allowed to return to
the uk
the duke and duchess of sussex highly
anticipated tv interview with oprah
winfrey is set to air in the u.s later
tonight
it marks the first sit-down interview
with the couple since they quit their
roles as senior working royals last year
in a clip released earlier this week
megan said it was really liberating to
now feel able to speak for herself
the interview with oprah winfrey will
air in the us
on cbs and the uk on itv at 9 00 pm
tomorrow
it comes as buckingham palace is
investigating claims the duchess bullied
royal staff at kensington palace
in reports about allegations of bullying
leveled at megan came after the
interview with oprah was recorded
megan has called it the latest attack on
her character in two clips released
earlier by cbs
megan said buckingham palace could not
expect her and prince harry to be silent
if it was perpetuating falsehoods about
them as she alleges
while harry drew parallels between the
treatment of his late mother
and finally a group of teachers have
filmed a parody video
ahead of the return of students to their
classrooms tomorrow
four teachers from the king's school in
rochester banded together for a lockdown
version of the 1995 take
that hit back for good it's sung by
school principal ben charles
head of the prep school tom morgan and
catherine openshaw headmistress
of the nursery and pre-prep school
chaplain father padfield also features
in the video the usual lyrics have been
changed to reflect the current pandemic
with the group
singing and i'm going to say that he's
not seeing them we'll be together
fingers crossed now for forever we'll be
fighting and forever we will be
so complete in our hope that we will
never be locked down again
let's see if the students take that to
number one in the charts but that is the
latest
here on sputnik news i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
correction a very very good friend of
mine i'll spare his blushes
who knows everything about the royals
he's a very big royalist
himself he knows everything he's
corrected me from a ghastly era
megan and harry are getting nothing
from the oprah interview it's
oprah that's getting the 10 million
dollars my good friend i'm very very
grateful for the correction
they have done the 100 million dollar
deal with
netflix and uh the book deal
is on its way uh but i shouldn't
leave the impression as uh
i would have done if i were not
corrected by my friend the sage of all
matters royal
uh that they're not getting paid for the
opera
interview the nhs workers are not
getting paid much either at least not
much
extra so my second poll of the evening
is do nhs workers deserve
more than a one percent pay rise it's
quite simple
it's binary if you're allowed to be
binary
these days a yes b
no you can vote on my twitter feed
now um i think i can say we have seldom
had
a post bag as voluminous
as divided and as acerbic
as the one we've had tonight on the
megan and harry
story which is why i'm particularly glad
that we are joined by my former
parliamentary colleague the right
honourable norman baker
former home office minister former
lib dem member of parliament another
scotsman i'm afraid there's a lot of us
around we have a footprint everywhere in
the country and
in the world he is an author a mean
mean mean author i tell you his book
the strange death of dr david kelly
is the the mainstay
of my film killing kelly which will be
out very soon
indeed and indeed the right honourable
norman baker is an executive producer
of that film now he presents on sunday
night his
own music show on radio
and he's been good enough to join us for
the
final hour and we'll be taking calls on
it
welcome norman baker
very glad to be with you again great to
see you
uh norman um
some people say that they don't
give a toss about royal matters
but they give a toss about it enough to
write
in enormous volume and at length
uh with their opinion on this
now you've written some cracking books
but you also wrote a book about the
royals
which if your publicist is listening
you ought to get back out there being
marketed right now because
you're the one that's got the sharpest
view
on these matters some issues
that many people didn't even know
existed
the secret votes for example in
parliament
the rote system the pre-legislative
approval that the royal family are
able to exercise for another
example so along comes the biggest royal
story
in many years this extraordinary fallout
inside the family give us your overview
of that first and foremost well the
first thing george to say and you'll
notice from political parties is that
when
there's a civil war inside a political
party or an organization
nobody wins so the palace isn't going to
win this one
and harry and megan aren't going to win
this one either and what will happen
is that respect for the monarchy will
decrease
and respect for harry and megan i think
will decrease and if you look at the
history of
tv interviews whether it's princess
dialer or whether it's prince charles or
prince andrew in his car crash
interviews everybody makes us
none of these interviews turn out well
do they
so you know i look at this and i look at
what people are saying some people are
saying harry and megan are badly done by
others are saying
um that they've let the queen down
my view is just a plague on both their
houses because they're all family
themselves
made it very difficult for megan to uh
incorporate herself they don't like
strong women
and they didn't like princess diana uh
first of all she was told at the same
thing in public for years
and their view of women is that they
should be
an adjunct to their man and be seen and
not heard
and just be a simpering psychic
norman but i know princess anne vaguely
uh she's about as strong a woman as it's
possible to be
ah yes but she's important to the family
i'm talking about people who've married
into the family
and they're outsiders and that's how
they're expected to behave so
megan didn't fit that uh that bill so
the palace has mishandled megan all the
way through
but having said that uh harry and megan
are rather
full of themselves you seem to think the
world is standing by to
listen to their powers of wisdom
whatever they drop from their mouths
and of course at the same time they're
exploiting the royal connection which
they're now disowning
in order to get massive massive amounts
of money from
netflix and everything else so i don't
have very much sympathy with them i
don't know about somebody with a royal
family either
let's go back then to uh first
principles
in what way did the royal family make it
difficult for megan i
you know more than me but they certainly
rolled out the red carpet for our
wedding
for the wedding yes but that was that
was an event they wanted to
promote themselves at you know i mean
what happened to megan was that she was
brought in there
she was told what she could wear she was
forced to have she had foisted
upon her grays and other unflattering
colours
she was told what term nail varnish
colours she could have
how to cross her legs not to speak in
public
she'd have to learn the ways the whole
family and and
try to submerge this personality which
he has
was not wise or achievable but that's
what they did
now you i mean you say all that i
presume you
know it or you wouldn't be saying it
you're not that sort of a
chap sounds a bit surprising to me but
i'll accept your
word for it but if you are going to be
if you're going to have royalty if
you're going to have a royal family
you do have to have everyone uh pulling
the same way
don't you let me give you an example of
what i mean
uh it is the job of the british royal
family
acting as the head of state
to have as decent relations as is
possible
with say the president of the united
states
therefore you can't have members minor
members of the royal family
openly insulting the president of the
united states
because they don't like his politics can
you
no i agree with that point but um the
key word you had now george was
minor if you look at other royal
families in europe whether it's the
benelux countries
or the scandinavian royal families they
have a much much i think the japanese
for the same matter actually
they have a much narrower raw family and
the royal family there
is the the monarch and his or her spouse
and the next in line and perhaps a
grandchild and that's it
they don't have these massive royal
families that we do you know the front
of my book
which you'll have mentioned and i'm
going to wave it to you here
44 members of the royal family on the
front of the on the balcony here what
are we all doing
why are we paying for these people so
harry and megan
because they're not directly in in line
in because charles and his child's
children are
then they don't have a role in the same
way they should be out there working
as indeed they are now doing it in a
fashion so you know because
the diarrhoeal family is so enormous
that's when you
try to apply that rule but it needs to
be that way one other difference is this
in the european monarchies you can have
a monarchy
in the benelux countries or the
scandinavian countries and in those
countries
they've moved with the times they
recognize democracy the monarchs
take a note of allegiance to democracy
in this country
we as subjects have to take care of
allegiance to an elected person
well you and i many times had to
swear our allegiance not only to her
majesty but
all all her heirs and successors
uh yes isn't it wrong that when we won
an election
fair and square uh we then have to take
another
elected personnel to discharge our
duties now to commons
it's entirely wrong which is why i never
swore it
on a holy book uh i instead
uh availed it i can't remember the word
now but i
i did so because i i wasn't prepared to
swear that falsehood on a bible
but if i had not taken the oath
and you the same we wouldn't even have
been allowed to
sit down let alone get our wages
i really got fined actually we wouldn't
find for it as well
no i mean i didn't swear on the bible
either and what i did was i gave my own
oath
um which which i gave uh studiously and
then then garbled through the official
one but when i read hansard the next day
what i've given as my oath didn't appear
all that appeared was the official oath
so even hansa was corrupted to reflect
this
yeah it's a big i mean
we've got the royal family we've got a
monarchy
it's not going to change in your
lifetime or mine norma
i think it is i think it is actually i
think it's going to change
after the queen gives way to prince
charles i think it will change then
because there's a lot of loyalty to the
queen
as a person and i believe that she's
done a reasonable job i don't think the
same thing applies to prince charles
and and his innocent successors so i
think it may well change
you think well britain will become a
republic
i don't know what happened in my
lifetime but i think we're moving in
that direction and
why i said to prince charles so you
won't take advice from me but what i
would say to him is this
the tree that doesn't bend is gonna
break if i were he
i'd be reforming the whole family pretty
damn quick well if i were he i'd be
passing the job on to my son william
who is who is terrifically popular i can
tell you
well of course that breaks a whole ethos
of hereditary principle
which is what they're desperate to hang
on to yeah
but let's go back then to megan and
harry
you make good points that they are minor
royals
and of course god forbid if anything
happened to
uh to charles and and william and
all of william's children then harry
gets the gig
but that's not likely and let's hope not
uh but minor will accept
um but they're making money out of
their royalness whilst
whilst micturating on royalness
that's hypocrisy isn't it it is
hypocrisy totally and
i'm all in favor of people being able to
walk out their own family
if they don't find it comfortable and
they'd rather be in los angeles then
good luck to them
i don't mind that at all but what they
can't do
is opt out to the royal family and then
trade on the royal family connection to
make a lot of money
i mean look we would not have these
people all over the world apparently
tuning in tonight
to watch harry and megan and that
wouldn't have itn
paying um itv paying was a million
pounds they paid a million yeah
if they weren't members of the royal
family so they won't have their cake and
eat it that's a problem
so you know let them go off and do what
they want to do i wish them well i don't
wish them any harm at all
but they should have surrendered their
hrh status just become private citizens
they're hanging on to that and they
shouldn't do
let's deal finally then with the
elephant uh in the room
the defenders of harry and megan
either infer or imply rather
or sometimes openly state
that it's because megan is
black she's not black she's mixed race
but she's politically speaking black
uh is there anything in that charge
well i think there's something in the
charge not that she's black particularly
but she's she's a
she's regarded i don't say this but i
think the palace regards was the strep
woman who should be in her place that's
their view on the matter
she's american which i don't like very
much and she's kind of upper teeth i'm
using nail words rather than my words i
think that's more of an issue than them
than anything else and i have to say you
know we've had this um
spin coming out of the palace this week
about um other bullying
i don't know whether it's bullying or
not there was evidence there was some
suggestion that bullying did take place
but that was years ago and the point is
that we've had bullying from prince
andrew for example
nothing's nothing to be done about that
there's been no palace inquiry about
that
and it's very convenient isn't it for
the palace has suddenly announced an
inquiry this week before the television
appearance
i mean that's a really bad spin
yes where will it all end
well it won't end happily it won't end
happily at all
and there'll be damage done and i think
uh charles needs to reflect on this
charles around the reality should
reflect on this
and if he wants the royal family
continue 50 years time you should have
to reinvent it a bit
there's no sign he's going to do that
and i think if he doesn't do that
uh then i feel we may be in for the end
of the royal family and
not in my lifetime but in 30 40 years is
going that way now
they're very out of touch with the
public at large
um and they're relying on the queen's
popularity well that's going to go at
some point
show us the front of your book again
norman if you would
there we are when norman
when norman sent that book to me
i almost didn't read it because i'm not
really interested
in the royals but it is an absolutely
riveting read it's a book about the
royals
but not as you know it not as you know
them
it's a look at the politics behind
monarchy
and some things in it are quite
eye-opening and
i was a member of parliament for almost
30 years i never knew them
till i read them in norman baker's book
norman thank you for that
and what do you do by norman baker is my
recommendation
for your reading list this week thanks
norman
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows
do nhs workers deserve more than
a one percent pay increase quite
shocking numbers
only 43 percent of you say yes
57 of you say no
what do you mean no call me
and justify that no
60 second break count them radio
sputnik
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
the airwaves this savannah
is a rigid dictomy of fact
and fiction as fisher says the
twittersphere where the slightest
misjudgment can spell
being cancelled
one species rules over the airwaves
through its ability to adapt and survive
and even the harshest environments
the george gatheway
[Music]
the top cat in these parts it is mostly
active on sunday evenings in britain
and mid-afternoon in the united states
it's seldom roars during the day
most notable for its wide variety of
address it protects these parts from the
mainstream media
you can catch this fine specimen on the
mother
of all talk shows
don't pick a fight with it they've been
known to bite back
you're listening to radio sputnik
[Music]
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends contributors
and callers everyone is welcome
now i'm spitting mad and if
you're watching on facebook you already
know the reason why
my interview that i've just conducted
there with the right honourable norman
baker
my former parliamentary colleague was
taken
down by facebook because
france de french tv
too put on a copyright complaint
claiming that they owned the interview
they owned an interview between me and
my former parliamentary colleague
norman baker
this is insane how could you possibly
own
me or norman baker
they then withdrew their copyright claim
but not before we'd lost 70 percent of
our facebook
audience so i'm here to tell you
france duh whoever you
are i am going to sue you
for a substantial sum of money
for loss of audience
because of your absolutely fraudulent
claim absurd and fraudulent claim
that you owned an interview i was
conducting live
with norman baker about the british
royal
family let's see majesty
you can take your own royals
to the timbrels and
decapitate them if you please but you
will not
stop me speaking to another british
parliamentarian
about the british royal family
so be
on your alert from
lawyers are coming to get you
in the morrow that means tomorrow
uh now here's a call from georgie in
spalding
on the nhs one percent pay rise georgie
welcome
hi george i'm good to speak to you
right i've not long long got in i've
only done a seven hour shift today only
half an hour
georgie almost 60 percent
of the votes say that you do not deserve
more than a one percent pay rise does
that
strike you as surprising well yeah
it does actually um but you know we've
got to listen to it um
what i'm thinking is do they think we
are just sticking up for ourselves um
i'm a member of a party that looks after
all workers
and you know any workers struggles like
the
british gas abysmal fire and rehire
thing
um anybody that's having any problems
i'm there i'm your man well i'm not your
man but you know what i mean
yeah and my main reason is the safety
aspect
patient safety because we won't ever be
able to attract
nurses into the profession if you have
if we don't value us basically
especially with a lot of nursing staff
from lower wage economies are no longer
coming here
and some returning absolutely
and the other thing is we're going to
lose staff as well and we're in this
tricky thing
where you know striking we want to keep
patients safe but
that is something that even the royal
college of nursing are talking about
and i believe they've got 35 million i
might have got that wrong in a strike
fund
ready um so this is quite serious stuff
i've spoken to my colleagues you know
just done an unscientific survey
and they're really hacked off with it
but you do still get some nurses that
will say
no there's not enough money where are we
going to get it from well let me tell
you and you know this yourself
that the wealth in this country and we
are the fifth or sixth
richest nation aren't we um it is
generated
by the workers the working class so we
do
there is a danger that we could look
like with separatists as it were and
we're just sticking up for ourselves
but that's not the thing the nhs is a
major employer as well isn't it so
you know we can't let them ride rapshod
over us and i think
they're going to if they get away with
this they're going to actually
undermine everything in the nhs they're
already privatizing it by stealth as you
know
and it's just going to get worse and one
percent with inflation it's actually
negative
and all we're actually asking for is a
restorative pay we're actually 20
down on wages and we're just asking 15
and um i think we should get it and i
think everybody should be behind us
because it's going to affect all of us
if you need if you need a
hospital you are going to need nurses
and it's not just the nurses it's all
the nhs staff sorry i've practiced on a
bit longer no you haven't uh you have
set the scene
for what is likely based on this poll to
be quite a contentious
uh point uh so do nhs workers deserve
more than a one percent pay rise georgie
in spalding uh believes so uh
but only 41 percent of you on the poll
do think so while 59
of you think the nhs workers do not
deserve more than a one percent pay rise
where does that mentality
come from thanks georgie for that call
now a copyright claim update france
tv is the french national
state owned broadcaster for france
they took this show off the air
there's the uh dispute claim
37 seconds of video belongs
to them 30 seconds of a live
interview between me and norman baker
the french state television claims
belongs to them well i am
as angry about that as it is possible to
be
the lesser majesty of it so
uh if you're uh watching i intend
to sue you the claim has now been
withdrawn
of course because it was perfectly
absurd and the stream has been restored
on facebook of course but not before i
lost
70 percent of my facebook audience
i've had it with these algorithms and
these
fake copyright claims the audience is
growing by the second as people are
coming back
but they lost an important interview
between me
and norman baker and i've just had it
i'm not going to put up with it
any more here's a call from guy
in stock on trent he's always worth
hearing go ahead guy
yeah good evening george yeah i'm not
with the group
think with uh megan and harry george
tell me i actually think i think that
mag has been vilified
oh yeah well well she's recently taken
the mail to crown court and she's won a
libel case
no it wasn't liable it was copyright uh
they printed
uh a letter that she had written to her
father a rather unbecoming letter
there was no libel involved there's no
doubt as to its authenticity
it was a copyright claim and she won it
yes
yeah harry's taken the same paper to
court
and the and the damages he was awarded
he's given to the
invictus games charity now
now there's numerous examples of how
uh the press have treated megan in one
way and kate in an opposite way
whether it's uh the way they caressed
the the bump when they were carrying the
child
kate it was a loving affair with meg and
it was showing it was for the cameras
whether it was the bouquet at the
wedding reception
um believe it or not apparently the
bouquet
megan carried was will put one of the
princesses
lives at risk now george i ain't
interested in the royal family but it
shows
the hypocrisy of the press and now that
couple has been vilified
now and i wish them all the luck in the
world and if they can sell
whatever it is they sell their life
story to whoever wants to buy
good look to him i won't be buying it i
don't buy a load i won't watch the
interview
i'm not bothered in them but but in the
same way as norman baker's interested in
the politics
you cannot dispute that that couple has
been vilified by
by the right-wing media tell me why you
think that is then
well okay then george why is it no i
don't i don't
you've given good examples i'm asking
you what why you think the media have
done that
as she as she has she refused to play
ball with the royal family
is is it that she won't do what she's
supposed to do
if you marry into the royal family
doesn't that presuppose you're going to
actually do the job
george i don't george i'm guessing
because
i've never been up there i've never been
up to the palace i don't know what you
need to do
what what i would say is that if this
family
does not um regroup and think what
they're going to do
they're not going to last a great deal
it's it's a terrible institution
it puts those people's lives under great
stress
and and and they're viewed from all
millions and billions of people in the
world
it's unhealthy uh yeah
you're right about that unhealthy it's
probably going to be the most
viewed interview in oprah's
history and she's had some blockbusters
what does it tell us about our societies
not just ours but american society which
is supposed to be
a republic what's the enduring
attraction of royalty do you think
all i can imagine is it's from the
cradle to the grave we're
we're nurtured that there's this supreme
family and
you know they're royals and their this
that on the other end
and many people but but there are many
people
who do not follow it and won't watch it
and aren't interested
very interesting thanks guy uh it's
always good
not to follow the herd and to
have your own point of view on it
i'm still shocked at the nhs poll and
it's actually getting worse only 41
percent of you
now think that the uh offer of
one percent uh is uh
not good enough uh terry says they made
their choice they should be free to live
their lives
how they like and sam says i wish
harry and megan would have their sussex
titles stripped
and go off into their own world no one
really cares about what they have to say
or whinge about so many more important
things
and merrick says everything every young
man dreams of but will never have
has been given to harry free of charge
palaces castles millions in the bank
the best food and drink best health care
best education
private jets which he flies around the
world shooting wild animals
while lecturing us about animal welfare
and climate change
and a hollywood actress for a wife who
wouldn't look twice at him
if he was skint for american viewer
skint means
you don't have any money uh instead of
whining and blubbering about how hard
life is
he should get down on his knees thanking
god for his great
unearned good fortune and mubasha
says i don't think i agree with you
about megan you say she is a second or
third-rate actress
from a third-rate show but at least she
has some talent
what talent does the royal family have
how did they accumulate all this wealth
why should we care so much about
them what about prince andrew where is
the investigation
where is the media coverage about him
like there is
about megan also what exactly did megan
say or do
to get so much hate how can they have
the audacity or dusty
to call her a bully considering how they
treated
diana and theresa says the public will
have been told
on a need to know basis the queen and
prince philip
welcomed megan she was invited to take
part
in the family celebrations before they
were married
which is very unusual what do they
want let's hear from ian in hounslow
on the nurses go ahead ian hello george
hi
um i'm a retired nurse yeah uh and i'm a
bit concerned about the health unions
trying to take some credibility
over waviness we're not happy with this
one percent
offer now they've got a poor track
record
particularly the rcm which colluded with
previous tory governments
to divide union efforts to get a fair
deal for workers
also they treated whistleblowers namely
graham pink
very very badly so they can't be trusted
do you know there were 75 000 assaults
on nhs staff last year
i didn't hear about 75 000 prosecutions
did you
no i'm shocked at that number they're
falling down on the job
uh there's lots of things they could
have done and they haven't done
like um the the nursing bursary which
was a disaster
charging nurses and doctors and cleaners
to park at the hospital where they work
uh and child care costs need two grand a
year
they haven't brought in workplace
crashes like we had during the war and
the factories
like they've got in parliament exactly
yeah these are working women working
mothers struggling to put food on the
table
especially if the husbands are on zero
hours contracts or even at work
uh and the unions really i think i
really got a case to answer
and it's this campaigning for another
one
it's a smoke screen for where they've
fallen down on the job that's all i've
got to say george well very powerfully
made thanks ian
let's go to eric in new jersey who's a
new caller go ahead eric
yes hi george how are you by the grace
of god i'm good just take your time
you're a new caller we want to hear from
you
all right um yeah george so i i very
much
enjoyed listening to your show and
hearing what
many have to say about a range of topics
um
the concern or the reason for my call
today
has to do with the um youtube
sort of threats that i saw that if
anyone
questions something about covid they'll
be banned
and that that just came off as very
concerning to me because
i feel that nowadays if
someone shows some skepticism or
questions
certain narratives they are immediately
labeled as a conspiracy theorist well
yeah
you you might well be a conspiracy
theorist but you're certainly not banned
you're on the air you're on the show no
go ahead
but go ahead and give me giv give me
your conspiracy theory
no no no no joe i'm not i'm talking
about the youtube
stream like i was if someone writes
on the youtube stream when your show is
live
it says there's a pin that says
if you mention any thing
against kovid and quote unquote is
conspiracy you will be
banned from the writing on the chat
well i i don't know about that obviously
i'm not on the youtube
i'm here in front of the camera so
you're on the show
tell me what you would have liked to
have written if you hadn't been
threatened with a ban
no i just it has to do with liberty
george of course i
i know yeah of course we this is a
pretty liberated uh
platform and a pretty liberated show but
it can't be
uh it can't be unlimited alas
because we are on other people's
platforms
and we don't want to get banned from
them eric
but if someone speaks against covet on
youtube they'll
you guys will get in trouble by youtube
yes for doing such a thing
well i presume i don't know what you're
talking about but that's
that is a logical uh inference i'm
making from what you've told me
uh we don't want to get banned from
youtube
or from facebook because that will mean
that none of the good things on this
show will be seen or heard by anyone
can you grasp that i can but the thing
is
is that i i feel that many people have
spoken out against
covet regulations regularly on youtube
and other sources so
i don't know that's where i don't know
where it's coming from i don't either
but
i'm asking you for the third time why
don't you give me a blast of your point
of view
all right well i'll have it i i all
right i'll ask you straight
does one have do you believe that one
has the right to breathe fresh air
george or are we
to be forced to breathe our own carbon
dioxide and wear masks forever
uh i don't think we're going to wear
masks forever in fact in texas
you no longer wear a mask at all
but if you're asking me is it common
sense uh in the middle of a
pandemic which is making millions
sick and a significant number of them
die
uh then i'm i'm a mask wearer i'm a
supporter
which is fine which is fine and i'm not
i'm not you know if you wish to
wear masks or do whatever you like go
right ahead but
when it's when they okay and let me go
back a bit
so here in new york in new jersey we
have dictators
who are have emergency power orders
which
by the way not dispute we we tried to
incorporate the philosophy of
montesquieu which to separate the
branches of government
meaning the legislature is supposed to
write the laws not the executive
branch now they've been granting
themselves emergency powers the same way
hitler did
and are putting forth mass mandates
which are just
out of control and putting tons of
people the small
mom-and-pop shops out of business have
been making everybody's lives miserable
as hell for the past
year and it's just absolutely disgusting
in my view
that people cannot speak against
mask mandates by dictators we have a
dictator murphy
governor of new jersey and we have a
dictator cuomo
governor of new york it's absolutely
disgusting and i think more people
should be allowed and able to speak out
again well
you have done so very uh eloquently and
loudly on this very platform so thanks
for doing it
richard is in manchester in
england not in the united states go
ahead richard
good evening george thank you ever so
much for uh for putting me on a great
show by manchester united today
absolutely wonderful totally wonderful
i'm so happy about it
can't wait to have i went to my
daughter's travel late lunch and then we
watched it together she said what do you
think dad what school i said but it's
going to be 3-0 for manchester united
she said i think you're crazy well that
was a good call i mean it didn't quite
get to three now but
uh i i i i was terrified of
today uh and so i'm even more
unusual they're happy yeah wonderful
george can i
talk to you please about um the scottish
nationalists from there
oh yes their effort to uh you know
depart from the uk uk which i've got
friends up in scotland and
they're a bit disappointed about the
whole thing the whole thing has become
the tide is turning though richard yes i
know i know i
i've seen the whole show again tonight
and i'm very pleased about that but
what happened with her she she's got
um she she just got this complex of
being
the queen of scotland eventually i'm
pretty sure
and i don't know why or how this has
grown
over the last few years i saw the
summoned interview with the committee
and i thought he did very very well and
i have no axe to grind
he was found not guilty by a court of
law
of which mrs sturgeon is the prime
minister as asserts the first minister
as she tells everybody
of the country yes and by the way
richard a majority of the jury which
cleared
cleared alex salmond on all charges
women women and the judge was also a
woman
exactly and and it's proven beyond all
doubt and then she goes on the show
on the uh in front of the committee and
it's told that under the guise of
giving a covid um uh chat
on the television one hour per day that
she said she did not agree
with that and that he was guilty that's
not word verbatim but no words
she gave that uh impression yeah she
didn't use those exact words of course
but she gave that
that is absolutely despicable george
to put an innocent man or threaten
in any way to to to put an innocent man
in jail for life and this is what is
coming out now
because everybody has been telling lies
and i don't know what you think but i
would expect some people
are going to go to jail for that i hope
so i believe that
they should um i think the
wheels have come off the conspiracy
against alex almond
and more and more people only one third
of the people in the poll this morning
think that nicola sturgeon has been
totally honest
about the alex almond affair i feel
vindicated when i started
out questioning all of this i felt uh
isolated and lonely
uh and attacked
but now as happens from time to time
uh well you look very relaxed tonight
george can i just take
yeah yeah quickly quickly richard very
quickly one more point it's about these
people
the old the the old brigade of hezeltine
and adonis and blair and campbell and so
on
are all trying to get us back into the
eu
and i noticed today that um
the the reform party uh unfortunately
they're going to lose lose their leader
but um
they they've come out with the fact that
you know they tried to smash
our democracy uh these people when we
were fighting for
four years a fight to get out of the eu
and now these very very very wealthy
people
are trying to get us back in yeah
although that's uh
like uh launching a campaign to
again uh insist that the earth is flat
uh the the british will never
rejoin the european union in fact
the existence of the european union is
a very much bigger question will the eu
continue
to exist thanks for the call rich john
in dorset
is up next go ahead john george
pleasure to talk to you mate um i don't
i don't quite know whether
that are spoiling the party here but i
just want to ask you what you think of
my opinion which is that the um
working man which i am well what until i
retired
um is is uh being demonized i think is
is a fashionable word to use well i i i
do feel that there is
a concerted effort to make us all look
like a load of nana's
yeah i do i think that uh working class
culture
working class language uh working class
uh self-identification and so on
are all under attack and have been
for really rather a long time
and the left is largely responsible for
that
yeah what passes to the left liberalism
is what i call it but they would call
themselves left
yeah so i mean you know personal
pronouns
identity politics uh the the whole uh
trans issue uh the the insistence that
everything is about
race and gender and sex uh
and color and so on all of these are
driving the working class
into a corner well i i think it's a
distraction george in my humble opinion
everything you just said there i totally
agree with
which is unusual for me because i like
to have a little chit chat
well look um i i see this as a bit like
the uh industrial revolution
except it's the computer revolution
i do think that all these uh huge great
multinational tech
tech companies uh are going to find the
working man is redundant basically
before
before they even uh i i think it's a
slow process but i think it's speeding
up
by the minute well yeah maybe but you
know everything
i'm looking around here everything i see
was made by a worker if you look out
your window everything you see
was made by a worker the problem uh
increasingly is that it wasn't made by a
worker here
it was made by a worker somewhere else
everything that we have and use and need
is grown by or made by
a worker so i don't believe that the
working class
is disappearing and i don't believe that
robots will
take over the world that we can do
without workers
obviously if we can cut the uh hours if
we can
cut the uh age of retirement
and so on because we can share the
workout
more uh uh conveniently then of course
i'm in favor
of that but we'll always need
the working class that's my view let me
just have one more quick point before
you go or i go
um you take an average street and you've
got two human beings there's one on one
side of the road
another one on this side of the road now
this bloke on my side of the road
goes out to work at seven o'clock in the
morning he comes back about eight
o'clock at night
and he's worked his ass off all day he
gets hammered by inland revenue
he winds up like i am now i've always
been self-employed
and unbeknownst to me i was uh working
against myself
without anyone i don't want to go on
about me but anyway the blank on the
other side of the road
signs on the dole now there are certain
people in the in the labor government
they seem to favor the per they seem to
they seem to
rush to him like an army of her uh
what do you call them care workers
social workers
i take care of him they seem to
look just because of the hour just
because of the hour john
i need to move on i would just say this
i believe in a society where if you can
work you must
work not should but you must work
but the if the society we're in
cannot offer you work then it is the
duty
of all of us to support the family
of the people who want to work but are
not being allowed to
work because of the system uh economic
system
that we have now there's a legend on the
line
it's norma in bristol go ahead norma
hello george um i saw this film this
afternoon called a united
kingdom now this was the story of um
prince suretzy karma's best genre it's a
wonderful film i've seen it
oh god yeah and he's marrying of ruth
williams and
the marriage wasn't accepted by both the
countries
but you see why i'm bringing that was
all the lies and all the cover-ups of
the british government
is in the latest 40s and 50s as you
probably know
and it showed tony ben helping suretzy
come to eventually get back
he did yeah yeah and that ruth williams
she was such a brave woman you know
i mean i found it ever so powerful it
was very moving film
uh i i liked it very much i'm surprised
that hasn't been a more successful
film well yeah i mean it was about five
years ago i think it was made
yeah but um you did mention on your
twitter account about um
you were so a tribute to your father you
know because
this is his death anniversary my father
yes 24 years ago today
yes and i can remember my mother who
died when i was quite young actually but
she was a great follower of
all the things going on in the world and
she said to me at the time
ruth williams was such a brave woman
because
oh those people had so much of a problem
between their country
our country but our government really i
mean i know
that i mean it is important the point
you make
because she suffered racism in
africa against her yeah and he suffered
racism
in britain when he was here against him
and she suffered racism or rather
she suffered from hostility from
people here in britain about her
marrying an africa
i know and i mean in the end uh he said
at the end of the film that
the son they had a son after the
daughter
is now the proper ruler of veteran
and and it you know it was it was a
happy
ending really for a problem but it was
it was quite heavy lifting to get there
uh it's called a united kingdom is it
it's called a you know it's a funny name
in it but it's trying to unite that
kingdom
yeah a united kingdom i i also recommend
it
it's a very very nice film with a happy
ending but a lot of struggle
to get to that happy ending of course
that's not to say i agree with kings and
hereditary power and so on i really
really
don't norma i don't know if you do are
you
are you a royal supporter no
i agree with a lot of the um norman what
was his name
yeah i i thought it spelled quite a lot
of sense really
anyway listen george had a lovely
birthday happy birthday
i did have a lovely one and i had a meal
delivered by my favorite restaurant
which i've told you about before and we
advertise it as box
e because they are delivered your
birthday dinner
fantastic it was brilliant many happy
returns
norma and regards to your husband thanks
very much
for the call the poll is closed
59 percent of you think nhs workers
deserve
do not deserve more than a one percent
pay rise
only 41 of you think nhs workers
do deserve more than a one percent pay
rise
that is quite remarkable it shows the
power
of propaganda the ease with which
workers can be divided uh
that uh the nurses get more than one
percent
takes no potatoes off your plate
if you say there's no money to pay
nurses more than one percent
then what about the trillions that we've
spent
in this catastrophe over the last
uh 12 months what about the hundreds of
billions
that we've wasted what about the
tens of billions that have been
possibly fraudulently siphoned
off to the friends and supporters
of the government party and in some
cases
even the family members i hope you're
angry
about these things and that you don't
allow yourselves to be turned against
the nurses who you were clapping for
not so many weeks ago
france tv i'm coming to get you
it's been marvelous thanks for watching
[Music]
you